pour ce match
Hikaru contre les vannes
on va mettre les chéquier ah mince comme
qui est d'une mauvaise couleur ah c'est
pas de bol c'était avec l'avènement de
ce weekend
on va recadrer ça bien comme il faut ne
vous inquiétez pas
et
en grand
et on va mettre les couleurs je vais
récupérer fabli sur discord
et on va être bon allez hop j'appelle
Fab
je vais récupérer la partie ici
la partie on l'a Lio yo salut tu
m'entends ça va ouais toi ouais ouais je
t'entends bien je vais te partager
l'écran attends j'ai les caméras du coup
qui sont pas bien cadrées
bien ça va tu es prêt pour ce magnifique
match ouais bon je pense que ça va être
à sens unique mais ouais je suis prêt
tu penses à sens complètement unique ou
tu penses pendant les 5 plus sains au
moins pendant un petit moment on va
avoir l'impression que
je pense qu'on aura pas trop
d'impression de rien du tout mais bon
ah tu penses que ça va être vraiment
sens unique de A à Z ouais genre tu
ramènes pas une
bah écoute c'est ton jamais mais non
tu crois pas connaissant Eco en général
tu crois pas à la petite vibration quoi
pas trop alors attends je vais te mettre
le partage je remets juste bien les
cames finissez en fait juste avant de
débrief un peu Levens si tu montes et tu
entends j'ai pas trop de voix ouais bah
c'est normal non
un peu malade c'est pas c'est pas revenu
encore mon Fab
par contre ouais attends j'ai un
problème avec les pendules en fait j'ai
eu un petit un petit truc imprévu
je sais pas je trouve pas les pendules
attends
je trouve pas la pendule j'ai un truc
qui était mal réglé
je vais te mettre le partage et je vais
me débrouiller pour récupérer les
pendules après
j'ai une pendule je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai pas l'autre en fait
c'est déjà pas mal
c'est déjà mieux que zéro pendule
exactement
j'essaie de me faire le chat fenêtré
déjà tu l'as
je vais essayer de vous récupérer la
pendule blanche
tu te sens un chat de fenêtre
le match va durer va durer 4 heures donc
bon
on a le temps quoi
peut-être que après une heure de jeu ce
sera déjà entre guillemets terminé quoi
ah oui mais bon c'est pas pour autant
qu'ils vont nous arrêter de match alors
maintenant tu as le droit de Quick le
match ah bon ouais à 10 minutes de la
fin tu as le droit d'arrêter ah oui bon
d'accord bon c'est déjà mieux que rien
mais oui bon
[Musique]
non après j'en sais rien enfin est-ce
que c'est bien de quitte le match ou pas
compliqué à dire mais
complexe complexe complexe
bon ben écoute ça joue hein il a cliqué
des quatre
attends je suis en train de tout mettre
et que je veux dire c'est mieux que je
regarde
le chat tu peux l'avoir ici si tu veux
non mais je veux dire sur le partage
d'écran je vais sortir mais je regarde
non
on est sûr de voir la même chose ok on
voit la même chose et mon micro dit bien
ça va le micro est bien en fait j'ai
pris le micro casque
au cas où
une belle chemise
ouais
mais c'est pas la chemise
non mais bon il a il a des choses après
je pense qu'il est aussi confiant que
toi parce qu'il a streamé toute la
journée avant il y a absolument rien à
[ __ ]
donc je pense qu'il est très confiant en
son
capacité de gagner
attends pour être tout bien prêt il me
reste plus qu'à
qu'à chopé le temps
le temps ouais c'est vrai qu'on va le
pendule de lever
de manière inexpliquée
je l'ai pas
mais bon
la voir
j'arrive pas à comprendre oui
c'est bon je les récupère je vais y
arriver et au moins après on sera
tranquille bon faut que les vannes
gagnent le maximum de parties alors
c'est ça le c'est ça le délire
à partir de plus simple ou plus si je
pense que le match peut devenir
équilibré
du grand il y a 2 minutes ok bon bah
tout à l'heure bien marché c'est cool
ouais ouais
ça a l'air d'être bien pour les blancs
non
probablement mais je sais pas
bon pour l'instant on a l'impression de
plus
après bon toute façon quand même si tu
fais [ __ ] des 6
j'ai trois peut-être ou je sais pas quoi
et que tu fais B4 tu as quand même des
condensations quoi mais bon après car
oui il va te faire il va sauter avec ses
pièces ça doit être plutôt mieux pour
les blancs mais bon
pas clair quoi pas fait encore
mais ok très bien pourquoi pas c'était
con et qui est en train de laisser la
casser 4 j'en sais rien
le Scorpion prend des cinq dames prends
des 5 et on peut pas reprendre le fou
des deux sur la Tour Eiffel
[Musique]
que les Blancs aimeraient bien faire
pour chasser ce qui valide des 5 et
enlever le pion aéré
donc ok à voir non c'est pas clair enfin
tu vois je sais pas trop après
le truc c'est que très souvent après en
manque de temps ça tourne en faveur du
carreaux les parties on a l'habitude
mais si on doit être objectif sur la
position c'est plutôt intéressant parce
que pions de l'event quoi ouais après
c'est vrai que le fou B2 il est
complètement bloqué contre le pion des
quatre quoi
plus les cases blanches
on va voir là il tape sur ces deux
peut-être tout rêve 2
pour défendre on va on va voir 30
secondes pour Yaro
entre deux
fourchette
ou pas
[Musique]
avion il a complètement troll aussi en
lui jouant que de la merde il a battu
assez facilement
il faut peut-être faire et aujourd'hui
même je trouve que c'est un peu du troll
de streamer 5 heures avant le truc quoi
ça fatigue normalement de streamer mais
lui il a l'habitude d'être très très
résistant
ils sont pas la fatigue
il faut quand même qu'il fasse gaffe
parce que cette première partie
oh bon
joueur évidemment on le connaît quoi
mais normalement sur le jeu rapide sur
internet il y a une différence
au championnat du monde sur Echiquier
d'ailleurs ikaro de rapides
moins quand même et le cavalier c'est 5
qui arrive pour les vannes
c'est un peu le scénario habituel avec
les parties du carreau c'est que c'est
pas clair il y a de moins en moins de
temps il te plante sa petite tactique là
le petit A3 qui passe bien pour chasser
le fou B4 et
là dans l'autre
et oui
et à mon avis ça va être ça pendant
pendant quelques heures aujourd'hui pour
pour les vents
quand il va réussir à prendre
quelques-unes
qui part
pour 14 secondes pour les deux âmes et
quoi il y a une ou deux secondes de une
seconde sur toutes les cadres le rajout
ne change pas ok donc une seconde c'est
pas beaucoup
non ça te permet pas de remonter ça te
permet juste de rester à flot tu
récupères pas de temps avec une seconde
qui fait mal avec des découvertes qui
vont arriver
allez en plus tu as vu dame B6 échec il
l'avait et ça tombe ça tombe
très très long pour les bonnes ce match
ça va être très très long pour pour les
Vans
parce que si tombe parce que il a pas de
souris ou je sais pas ce que je parle à
l'impression qu'il joue de chez lui j'ai
l'impression qu'il joue depuis un bar
je sais pas ouais il y a le mur en
brique derrière qui donne l'impression
qu'il est pas chez lui mais bon après la
loi d'avoir cette décocher de lui aussi
ouais mais en fait on a déjà vu la déco
de chez lui c'est pas ça peut-être qu'il
y a plusieurs pièces
[Musique]
je sais pas quoi je pense qu'il y en a
rien à [ __ ] aussi
le même truc sur un vrai échiquier
spécifiquement compris kahoot tu dirais
j'ai une chance j'ai un mec comme Les
Vans
mais sur internet en fait j'ai
l'impression que tu es battu d'avance
quoi
ces trucs il est là quoi
royalement les boulards les vans c'est
sûr mais ils ont fait une faute sur le
design enfin je sais que c'est pas toi
mais attends ça peut être ah tu veux
dire
c'est juste un truc que je peux pas
je peux pas prévoir avant le match en
fait et puis voilà c'est ça
donc en gros c'est après ça va être le
score du premier match que je peux le
savoir et que je peux après
mettre mais après faut que je réussisse
à mettre les noms des noms du bon côté
je te laisse faire moi je parle un peu
de la position pendant ce temps donc
c'était une Anglaise vertu donc c'est
une sorte de sicilienne inversée ce
qu'on a là
position équilibrée une fois de plus
les blancs bon ils vont simplement
essayer de roquer et faire tourner un B4
expansion les dames
trop de soucis pour l'instant dans sa
position
mais avoir après qu'est-ce qu'il peut
faire peut-être jouer avec C6 D6 sentir
le foot de caisse blanche et puis
peut-être essayer de faire des cinq un
jour
on peut échanger les cames pourquoi
faire
pour bien jouer voilà il prépare B4
moins de 3 minutes pour pour les vannes
on a vu que ouais quand il y a peu de
temps ça risque de mal aller pour les
vannes malheureusement
si des gens 5 minutes ça manque de temps
imaginant 3 et en une
donc là les carreaux qui réfléchit à
fond il fait ces 6 couvre relativement
logique on va dire pour fermer la grande
diagonale
ça évite que ça tape trop sur sur B7 et
il prépare peut-être des 5 à venir par
la suite arriver vers 7 c'était
peut-être possible d'aller de l'autre
côté vers à 7 ou je sais pas mais
pourquoi pas en gros il veut un peu
immobiliser le pion B4 pour profiter le
pion à trois derrière donc pas laisser
B5 trop vite
c'est un choix qui de toute façon est
sympa pour le Nord parce que tu es
content tu ouvres la colonne A et active
et c'était change pas tu te dis je
laisse le pion à 3 je pourrais toujours
faire un B plus tard
et je vise là-bas donc en fait j'ai
l'impression que les deux coups étaient
étaient bien
ils peuvent revenir au même vu que c'est
toi qui a le choix à côté noir en tout
cas lui il a choisi de prendre direct et
de faire des seins qui est oui bon il a
résolu en tout cas tous les problèmes de
l'ouverture avec les Noirs il a un beau
centre il est un peu fermé cette
diagonale du foie F3 il va pouvoir finir
le développement avec vous aussi sous
fou je sais pas F5 fois je trouve
quelque part s'en fout de quasiment en
tout cas il va sortir et ça va le faire
sur Internet parce que je suis sûr qu'il
fait ça fait des jouets en plus que ça
fait moins bien joué parce que là les
vans ça me paraît vraiment
beaucoup le temps qu'il utilise
pas j'en sais rien c'est vrai que c'est
étonnant la gestion
temporelle de Levan
ouais faut pas se mettre derrière autant
clairement c'est jamais bon on Blitz et
tu te sens plus contre maca qui peut
accélérer donc
il a pas de coïnant mais qu'il fasse
fouger 5 qui fasse fouger d'eux qui
fasse dame je sais pas quoi enfin ça
passe je vais maintenant la partie quoi
mais en plus il a pas bien joué parce
que là la position des noirs elle est
agréable ils ont gagné le centre et en
plus comme tu disais ce pion B4 c'est un
peu une cible il y a la colonne pour la
tour enfin
il a pris du temps il a rien fait
d'exceptionnel et il est quand même
moins bien
ouais non c'est pas et tu sens qu'il y a
vraiment côté psychologique non
ouais c'est bien possible enfin qui
partent dans ce match un peu d'avance
donc il va pas jouer de grosse prépa qui
va pas il va même pas peut-être tout
donner enfin sans le faire exprès je
veux dire
parce que là c'est vraiment une
spécificité quoi
donc ouais ouais c'est enfin je suis
contre une grosse différence
bon après c'est aussi le format qui veut
ça peut-être que si tu joues en partie
enfin si on te met 4 heures de bus
d'affilée contre Carlson je suis pas
peut-être le faire la même chose ouais
ça te fait peut-être la même chose en
fait ouais
je pense que ouais ton idée de mettre
des ko qui est un score ou ça s'arrête
c'est pas bête quand même
parce que là ouais ça va être long pour
les vannes en gros tu sais que tu joues
pour rien quoi tu joues et tu vas perdre
c'est dur
mais en plus ça se voit que c'est dès la
deuxième partie faites ça se voit que
les vannes il est déjà abattu quoi c'est
d'abord la première ouais c'est dur quoi
enfin c'est
la première année la deuxième mais elle
a fait ça fait 5 6 ans que ça dure un
moment tu te dirais il a perdu que
contre Carlson en fait il a gagné tous
ses autres matchs c'est impressionnant
déjà
et il a deux minutes d'avance
il a pas pris B4 je pensais qu'il
fallait prendre des quatre
B6 ou un truc comme ça
ça va être grave
je sais pas il va faire un chipo à un
moment un truc
alors après de temps en temps les vannes
sont sortira mais oui sur 10 parties
comme ça ils vont perdre 7 quoi
c'est un peu beaucoup
alors c'est des parties sans histoires
ou ouais non tu devrais faire 10 nuls
sur 10 parties quoi
après bah voilà il se va bien enfin en
fait il a pas du tout pas mal mis sa
tour qui vise de 5 qui vise B7 qui
défend B4 donc elle a un beau rôle
il maintient sa position mais ouais
quand même c'est la pendule quoi
après il a bien joué
mais manque de temps c'est chiant parce
que là c'est une décision que tu fais H5
est-ce que je sais pas tu vois
d'essayer de défendre B4 elle a le droit
de faire d'autres coups dame G5 et là
c'est trop difficile de faire toujours
le bon choix sans temps
c'est compliqué
ça va être du clic au hasard mais des
fois ça va pas passer ça sera toujours
plutôt dans la bonne direction parce que
c'est un joueur de
il est bon quoi il a un bon feeling ou
quoi mais dans le calcul précis quand
t'as pas le temps tu as pas le temps
donc
il y a des positions que tu peux pas
jouer l'intuition
il y a peu de position en fait tu peux
jouer que l'intuition malheureusement
de date du match mvelo 2 jours c'est
mercredi c'est simple de se rappeler
c'est ça tombe sur ma robe France
au moins c'est facile
au moins ça rappelle très facilement
ça tombe en plein dedans
enfin 19h22h30
je commencerai avec Baki mais on vous le
dit tout de suite on va mettre le foot
aussi à côté
on a déjà raté
le quart de finale mais je pense que
Maxime mettra lui aussi le match à côté
peut-être pas tout le temps mais il
regardera en tout cas ouais et là ça va
peut-être perdre de nouveau pour les
Vans
entre le temps la pendule
[Musique]
à faire un truc pas mal mais
ça mange le pion des ouais c'est ça
par échec roi actif pion de plus enfin
et bientôt
ça tournait d'un coup il a tenu le truc
à un moment ça tient plus quoi
il était en légère souffrance toute la
partie moins de temps et il se fait
arnaquer c'est même pas le mot en fait
sa technique
c'est une fois je veux contre un mec qui
joue avec un ordi
j'avais pas beaucoup de temps et je me
suis pris le pâté
contre un ordi c'est vraiment dur
il y avait l'option une époque sur
de jouer contre l'ordi
je croyais que j'avais réussi à tourner
j'étais très heureuse que je savais que
c'était ordi
mais malgré tout
défend bien quand même les vannes
genre 1% de chance de gagner le match là
je crois que
c'est trop
c'est la seule j'ai l'impression qu'à la
souris il est pas très fort
donc ouais c'est la seule où il a une
chance c'est il va sûrement la perdre
bah ça part mal déjà
quand tu as
quand tu es un peu comme ça c'est dur de
donner 100 % en plus plus le match
avance plus tu as envie de que ça
s'arrête quoi
en fait ça c'est un truc dans le sport
je sais pas si vous ressentez ça aussi
pour les gens qui ont fait d'autres
sports mais je passe comme super match
de tennis et que tu es mené de 7-0 et
qu'on dit il va falloir en jouer encore
45 en fait tu as qu'une hâte c'est que
c'est que le match s'arrête en fait fin
tu as qu'une envie c'est de les perdre 0
et
de partir le plus vite
ouais enfin sauf si tu crois que encore
une chance c'est le jour où tu sais que
c'est fini
au tennis c'est moins le casque que
c'est mais je passe comme si au rugby
après 40 minutes tu es mené 75 à zéro
très envie de retourner sur le terrain
le tennis c'est pas un bon exemple parce
que c'est des sept mais donc tu peux
toujours remonter mais oui la 75 zéro ou
au foot c'était mené 7 ou 8 à 0 à la
mi-temps c'est relou ah mais j'imagine
au tennis quand tu as Roland conte Nadal
et que tu es mené de cette zéro et
Machin ça se finit quoi mais bon
en face tu vois c'est dur mais du temps
je pense c'est des mecs qui ont eu déjà
eu des matchs difficiles qui sont
arrivés à faire tourner mais mais oui le
tennis c'est un peu bizarre enfin
spécial parce que tu reprends à zéro
tout le temps non mais là tu imagines
tu as déjà aucune chance et il te reste
encore 3h32 jeux
c'est vraiment comme si au foot je sais
pas tu démarres tes mené 15-0 et tu dois
jouer 90 minutes bon
c'est dur de jouer juste en fait donc là
pour les vans c'est vraiment difficile
de
juste rester dans le match en fait
complètement non mais ça dépend à quel
point tu y crois en fait mais plupart du
temps tu crois plus trop quand c'est
quand tu es trop dépassé quoi
il croit peut-être encore un tout petit
peu parce que c'est un sportif et que tu
as toujours un peu d'espoir mais il va
vite être douché et après ça fait
toujours plaisir d'affronter des Gods
j'imagine
ok mais faites à rognan il est pas en
dessous de Hikaru en fait si on a rien à
[ __ ] je pense
qu'il est même au dessus dans sa il a
même une plus belle carrière qui Caro en
fait les vannes
très clairement donc
c'est sûr qu'il s'en fout complètement
en fait enfin il considère pas les
carreaux comme étant des plus grands
joueurs de l'histoire des échecs ça
c'est sûr
non oui enfin c'est à dire que des gens
comme nous on serait peut-être contents
de jouer un peu ICO bon après pendant 4
heures d'affilée non mais
oui non il s'en fiche en fait oui il a
joué contre les meilleurs il a joué à
jouer tout le monde déjà puis il a quand
même menacé de gagner des candidats il
était leader des candidats etc bon il a
gagné les Olympiades avec son pays bon
ils en font un petit peu quoi
oui bon hospitchaess c'est pas ouais
c'est pas son objectif principal
mais oui donc du coup c'est pas c'est
pas facile de rester mobilisé comme ça
donc
pourquoi pas du clouage
il peut attaquer un peu ses six bon qui
est défendu comme ça
bon je connais pas trop l'évaluation
mais j'aimerais plutôt un peu mieux les
noirs a priori
par le dynamisme des pièces qui est des
trois très bien placés très chiant et
mais bon
pour se lancer dans le match peut-être
une rapidement qui revient à dodo ou
quoi tu vas dire oui bon ça va je
reviens dans le match car où il a un peu
il stream avant machin ou quoi il doit
dire oui bon enfin je suis tellement
favori que je fais comme je veux puis
peut-être à un moment donné tu lui un
peu sous pression et là tu as une vraie
chance quoi
pas disons en fait
il est beaucoup plus fort sur internet
mais
ça peut arriver que tu fasses tilter des
gens si jamais ils vont se faire
plusieurs mauvaises parties d'affilée
tactique de tactique des trucs qui
n'arrive pas normalement bon bah qui
joue quand même très mal avec les Blancs
les catastrophiques il est très mal
après bon tu vois on sait jamais avec
lui il peut se trouver des ressources
mais là c'est foutu enfin si je fais
dominer complètement mais après il va
faire le dos rond et c'est de la tenir
donc ça serait important que les Van
gagne
justement parce que s'il y a une pomme
même comme ça
ça va donner encore plus confiance les
carreaux d'être tranquille et confiant
dans ce match
tu dis ok même quand je fais n'importe
quoi il m'arrive rien ça va
je comprends pas pourquoi il se présente
il a pas envie de jouer mais en fait
c'est comme dans tous les sports c'est
juste une qualifié pour des trucs pour
enfin tu joues des trucs pour gagner de
l'argent pour te qualifier et puis après
des fois tu te retrouves
à un moment de la compétition je joue
contre quelqu'un qui est trop fort pour
toi c'est un peu comme je sais pas un
gaz Canada quoi il a perdu toute sa vie
contre lui bon
d'espoir enfin tu sais
tarif pour une énième fois c'est
qualifié tu es obligé de jouer et
il se trouve que ça dure 4 heures donc
c'est psychologiquement difficile
c'est juste difficile en fait ça c'est
je sais pas pourquoi c'est dur à
comprendre à chaque fois mais
c'est pas évident quoi c'est je passe
comme c'est un truc que tu aimes pas
trop faire et que ça va durer un quart
d'heure bon bah c'est une chose mais
c'est d'ailleurs 4 heures c'est chiant
quoi
c'est dur
allez pour vous
non enfin après
sur internet il joue bien ça dépendra
sur internet tu vraiment très bien donc
peut-être sur un vrai échiquier par
contre contre Naka il aurait 0 chance
mais sur Internet peut-être
les petits princes des petits astres
quand ils avaient 14-15 ans ou un poil
plus mais bon c'était tout petit quoi
mais en pro enfin depuis qu'ils sont sur
le circuit ATP il a jamais gagné je sais
pas si il a pris un 7 en fait c'est pour
te dire à quel point le problème mais
après je dois dire que même Gaëlle qui a
jamais gagné contre Joko il était il a
eu de balle de match quand même je pense
que c'est beaucoup plus serré par
exemple un
Djoko mon fils que un Levan eikao dans
ce format pas ce format là il est chiant
je pense que tu as vraiment eu dans ce
format enfin oui mais autant de choco
mon fils tu les ferais jouer 42 7 je
pense qu'il a aucune chance Gaël mais en
de cette gagnant il a une chance quand
même
[Musique]
donc ouais le format frais que là tu as
vraiment aucune aucune aucune fin
ça favorise pas le le côté imprévisible
en fait de la
on essaie d'être très très sûr donc
ouais c'est pour ça que c'est plus dur
psychologiquement
qui tourne bien tu prends un set le mec
un peu blessé je sais pas il y a des
mondes en fait
mais il y en a un peu plus
dans tous les sports
sur un match c'est un match quoi
bon on va voir
on va voir s'il réussit à la gagner ce
que je suis même pas sûr qu'il gagne
cette partie Fab non de moins en moins
je sais pas si c'est objectivement
gagnant d'ailleurs ce truc qualité de
plus il y avait pas de cavaliers ça le
serait pas
il y a plus que des pions surrénales
quoi
mais après la question c'est ce qui peut
la perdre en réalité faut pas tomber
je crois pas qu'il joue pas par contre
il va échanger
ça c'est nul j'en suis sûr
je ne sais où on D4 par exemple
une partie relativement mauvaise pour
son niveau
il fait nul aussi facilement ouais c'est
flippant
mais il est vraiment très fort il est
incroyable
mais après ce qui est beau c'est que
l'algorithme donnait plus de chance à
l'évène contre ricaru que au match de
demain entre Carlson et Carole
il donne quoi sur
7030 pour toi
. ok c'est serré
voilà c'est un match ça peut tourner des
deux côtés
peut-être qu'il va gagner les impression
aussi enfin pas trop regarder la
position parce que le roi elle est passé
par H3 et remonter peut-être qu'à 4
contre 3 c'est gagné
mais peut-être il va la perdre en fait
parce qu'il a plus de temps et il y a un
cavalier pour Hikaru donc il doit être
gagné objectivement
pour cliquer quoi faut pas tomber quoi
ce serait terrible trois défaites autant
ça fait chier quoi
la deuxième elle était méritée
déjà ok il a un poil moins bien mais
c'était loin d'être fini la position non
mais là je pense qu'il va la gagner en
fait la position des des blancs elle est
trop catastrophique il y a pas de temps
ah mais oui il est en train de jouer
juste la pendule
c'est terrible
ça part de là
quoi non non
une petite viennoise
des gens qui croient en carwan non mais
caroanna demain c'est contre Carlson en
un verre c'est impossible en fait
vie et top 3 mondial on Blitz sans réel
non mais en fait si jamais tu as trois
mondial en vide
sur le classement officiel de Blitz il
est ridicule ouais
un peu chelou
pas trop bien se passer
c'est impossible qu'on soit l'Espagne
Maroc et puis on verra enfin
c'est là tu dis sur une partie les
vannes ne peut pas gagner contre contre
macaf en bo2 par exemple on te dit ok
c'est possible mais pas en 25 parties
enfin c'est pas comparer l'incomparable
sur le format sauf peut-être aussi
bon d'accord on sait jamais quand même
ce serait possible alors pas sur
Internet parce qu'il a des problèmes de
connexion pendant ces matchs mais
sur les chic et pourquoi pas il avait
battu à la simcith up en départage donc
tu as des joueurs qui peuvent l'utiliser
bien sûr
ils sont pas nombreux
mais bon Maxime on oublie c'est enfin
genre c'est pas n'importe qui quoi nepo
aussi même si j'ai du caractère
comme tout le monde sur le même truc
mais
mais bon quand c'est sur une partie ou
un match sans en deux parties trois
parties en fait
et même en six parties les rennes il
pourrait battre
il serait pas favori à bien sûr
Doodle ça peut il serait pas loin d'être
favoris mais ça peut
boire il est peut-être un poil mieux un
peu plus d'espace peut-être qu'il va
mieux arriver à prendre la colonne E bon
c'est pas énorme mais
sur Internet ben Carlsen il a gagné tous
ces matchs de speechs contre Naka je
crois qu'il y en a eu deux il les a
gagné assez facilement les deux
d'ailleurs
sans forcer et sur un des deux il était
malade en plus Magnus
je crois qu'il était grippé où il avait
un gros rhume ou un truc comme ça
bah ça va ça là encore ouais
bon après
pas saute plus ou moins égal mais
en tout cas pas de souci
que ça prenne pas trop l'eau
vous êtes confiant écoute ouais
on verra je sais pas trop
c'est pas mal mais bon c'est pas non
plus
enfin je suis pas méga confiance
mais pour moi c'est genre 55 ans
oui oui c'est ça
pas confiance
non plus un peu comme contre nepo en
réalité
je pense plus fort non c'est machin
comme ça Internet
sur sur
un épaule il a jamais trop pris au
service de ces trucs
quoi mais tu vois je me souviens pas
qu'il est fait de grands résultats dans
aucun truc internet alors
après je suis étonné il jouera pas de
championnat du monde de Blitz c'est
rapide une nouvelle fois ça m'étonne
toujours
mais c'est loin c'est au Kazakhstan
c'est
les chansons qui a une certaine flemme
se déplacer soit en fait
j'en sais rien mais
pas vraiment fait les tournois pour se
qualifier au candidat non plus quoi
non
il avait pas très bien joué
peut-être qu'il a gagné mais pour rien
le dernier en fait
moi je compte pas de fin une fois qu'il
y a plus dangereux
je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
il commence à mettre la pression la
petite à petit
à la pendule à la position aussi
ce pion dessin que la surcasse blanche
est-ce que le nombre de rapides je crois
que c'est demain les joueurs sont donnés
pour le moment il est pas annoncé
a priori il devrait y aller mais bon on
sait jamais
c'est demain donc si il s'inscrit pas
dans les 24 heures où c'était où c'est
aujourd'hui
mais je comprends pas trop ce qu'il
retient de jouer en fait
je sais pas en tout cas si quelqu'un
peut dire s'il est sur la liste mais il
était pas sur la liste des inscrits et
la deadline est vraiment proche non
c'est étonnant si je joue pas mais
tu fais comme il veut
peut-être ça le fait chier
petit boss comme un fou des fois faut
jouer quoi faut pas faire que travail
en fait
je sais pas si tu as plein de gens qui
préfèrent juste Blitz ou jouer à
l'arrache sur Internet ou faire de la
merde
patouiller non après évidemment un
tournoi c'est un côté motivant Dréal
etc mais
c'est souvent long
puis là tu vois il fait froid et c'est
pas des dates de génie je peux
comprendre sans
toute façon c'est super chiant quoi
mais en fait le truc c'est que
normalement en fait tu vois pas trop ça
quand tu joues tu es pris dans le rythme
tu vas faire tes tournois
tu prends ton avion tu y vas et puis
voilà
je crois qu'il a un match de Bull de
d'ultra belette qui est prévu contre
narrow enfin bon
beaucoup plus intéressant
on se sent la petite nul faut pas tomber
les vannes
je veux rien de spécial et puis il se
passe rien quoi
elle défend ses pions et puis c'est tout
ça c'est même les blancs qui pressent
non quand même
je sais pas ce que tu peux faire en fait
pensez visuel mais bon
il me fait peur avec sa pendule Levan en
fait je vois bien que la position elle
va mais
après
deux secondes
c'est sûr ce qu'il a fait une petite
tête de côté
il va vouloir essayer de faire tour à 8
replacer sa tour remettre son roi en
fait si je pour gagner et carreaux c'est
terrible
avec sa tête de côté quoi
c'était une tête de côté de fou baisser
donc là il veut F5 quand même
et attaquer la tour ok donc il fait
lui-même
OK
mega statu quo
il est très heureux
je vais tout de suite il est très très
heureux
blocage
c'est 6 tu peux même ne rien faire avec
les Blancs
je la montre à fond
au milieu des trucs
c'est 5 minutes de pause là ok il y a
qu'une pause
[Musique]
à la moitié des 7 des 7 des
ouais mais elle est belle
je sais pas trop qu'en penser pourquoi
pas
pourquoi les vannes a fait l'échange
d'État
c'est pour attaquer tu as vu sur la
colonne il a attaqué les le pion c'est 7
colonnes
il était 13 heureux je pense
oh il était pas mal en fait je sais pas
objectivement comment c'était mais
c'est que la première phase non là c'est
la mi-temps de la première phase c'est
la moitié de la première phase là
après il y aura une deuxième phase avec
aussi une mi-temps au milieu une
troisième phase sans mi-temps ah bon il
y a pas de mi-temps
malheureusement il y a pas de il y a pas
de pause dans le dernier set
qu'on a un peu déçu
et bonne semaine
que tu passeras demain pour le match de
Magnus
ça veut aussi ça leur non c'est pas un
BO6 en fait
c'est 4 heures de jeu enfin c'est 3h30
de jeu avec les poses ça fait 4 heures
c'est un ça marche pas en terme de
nombre de parties ça c'est une terme de
temps pas la cette semaine
merci encore d'être venu à la backup ce
weekend merci à toi
mais non ça marche pas en nombre de
parties ça marche
en temps
ce qui arrive jamais aux échecs c'est le
seul tournoi sur ce format
après il y a des beaux matchs mais il
faut que
faut que les niveaux soient équilibrés
quoi c'est vraiment indispensable
qu'un joueur peut abandonner ouais il a
le droit d'abandonner à partir de 10
minutes de la du terme du match
tu peux arrêter avant la fin des dix
dernières minutes
pourquoi
non mais une fois que tu as déjà fait
3h50 de jeu tu t'en fous tu peux faire
tes idées à la minute
ah ouais mais moi dans les matchs que
j'ai commenté les mecs étaient distancés
mais je crois qu'ils oublient même qu'il
pouvait abandonner ouais c'est ça enfin
peut-être tu pourras abandonner j'allais
te dire très tôt quoi
de 8 points ou quoi tu as le droit de
dire stop peu importe le temps qui
ça reprend dans une minute
ça sera notre jour fine fly ce match il
va finir peut-être à 1h du matin à peu
près ouais
donc non il va pas jouer après
mais par contre jeudi les deux
demi-finales s'enchaîneront Fab
de quoi et demi finale seront jeudi
elles s'enchaîneront normalement
et demain est-ce que ça tombe aussi
pendant une demi-finale de Coupe du
Monde ou pas
à 20h aussi
à 20
demain ta mercredi et ta samedi dimanche
mais samedi c'est ma 3e place c'est ça
un peu mais les gens regardent parce que
c'est par le foot dans le mouvement quoi
mais c'était pas censé d'ailleurs
boycotter cette Coupe du Monde de base
ce que je disais j'avais envie mais en
fait
de la Coupe du Monde de base
non mais je pense ça reste mauvais
endroit l'organiser et c'est pas les
bonnes dates mais bon
en plus il y a de fou c'est que des
matchs complètement débile quoi
si j'arrive en finale
de pas venir jouer
et quand le final c'est dimanche
d'ailleurs
bon au moins ils évitent la finale de la
Coupe du monde
non ils enchaînent à fond ils en mettent
un peu tous les jours
ouais je sais pas si c'est bien de tout
faire en une semaine ou 6 millions en
étant étalé mais bon au moins ce sera
fait ce sera réglé quoi moi c'est cool
après je saute
que j'ai trouvé bizarre c'est que le
ceux qui jouent le dernier quart de
finale donc Maxime et saut il doit
enchaîner quart de finale demi-finale
finale sans jour de repos au milieu
je trouve ça un énorme désavantage
après c'est peut-être moi qui suis
matrixé par les jours de repos
bon on a tellement l'habitude avec les
tournois que
non mais en soi pour la pour le coup là
les speechers c'est vraiment intense ah
ça je me doute en fait
mais c'est 4h ou tu joues tout le temps
et tu as pas de pause mais tu as
vraiment pas de pause quoi tu finis ta
partie claque ça reclique quoi c'est
après tu as des pauses entre mais oui
en fait je sais pas moi je pense que je
entend le joueur j'en sais rien mais il
me semble vis de loin je préférerais
avoir une minute de pause entre chaque
partie que 5 minutes à un moment
aléatoire comme ça au milieu d'un truc
du coup Caro qui me joue une petite
finale
de base c'était 3h30
mais c'est les joueurs qui déposaient
tout le temps sans pause quoi c'est
clair quoi et donc pendant 4 heures
encore plus
je verrai bien la gagner la finale Laïka
ouais mais je trouve que c'était
vraiment stylé les deathmatch
Maxime je trouve que c'était même au
dessus du speedcha en fait
un peu en mode défi ou en fait tous les
mois il prenait deux gars ouais bah il y
en avait eu un c'était trend contre
c'était trentes comment il s'appelle
William je pense ok les Anglais
oui c'est pas mal enfin équilibré quoi
le match en fait c'était des défis
c'est des défis entre
des joueurs de même niveau et c'était
pas forcément des top top mais ça
pouvait être des top top aussi le genre
de couilles Maxime contre Caro j'imagine
ça Maxime je sais plus contre qui
c'était Evan nous dire
à contre André Maxime
il jouait plus je pense Maxime avait
gagné
un peu du clic comme ça quoi c'était
sympa c'est une fois par mois
un peu le Beats
c'est un peu ouais un peu comme j'avais
jamais pensé mais ouais c'est un peu ce
même
c'est le même truc
sauf qu'il reprenait pas forcément le
vainqueur je pense ouais c'est quoi le
prochain tour
non il y avait trop d'événements là en
décembre et avec le speech et tout
reprendre en janvier tranquille ou un
truc comme ça
vous février peut-être
ça a bien pour les blancs quand même la
position
bah ils ont la petite caisse
et si tu es une affaire de fou bah c'est
toujours ça de prix dans une position
relativement ouverte c'est clair que
c'est un petit c'est un petit truc
est-ce que ça a déjà vérifier le cas au
phénoménal que c'est pris très mais moi
je trouve pas qu'ils sont pris un café
au phénoménal en fait
enfin
sérieux quand tu vois quelqu'un qui
tombe KO
va je sais pas je trouve pas qu'ils sont
un cas au phénoménal j'ai pas vu d'image
on voit des combats phénoménaux mais qui
prend une droite il est par terre
du tout en fait
c'est parce que c'était
vraiment tu arrêtes jamais
bon intéressant
ça a l'air d'être un bon choix
il a peur de fou
en l'air enfin bon vite fait parce qu'il
y a peut-être des tours mais je veux
dire bon ça peut peut-être être pris un
moment
alors moi j'aurais été habitué se battre
encore pendant oui c'est juste pas vu
quoi
avec moi ça s'arrêtait pas tout de suite
je te le dis tout de suite ils ont fait
combien de matchs ils ont bien rempli
leur sol non je sais pas ils ont fait 10
matchs non je crois pas
que ça allait très bien marché en vrai
ce qui est pas énorme pour un truc aussi
IP aux États-Unis
ouais tu le vois ouais il a un peu
hagard quoi tu vois il est pas très bien
mais bon c'est
bon c'est de la boxe en même temps c'est
pas
et pour non
et du coup je peux défier à moi
tu peux
vas-y
[Musique]
l'entraînement physique à fond quoi
je crois qu'avec toi il faudra un autre
type d'arbitrage Fab
mais ouais je pense que l'arbitre
évidemment il a arrêté parce qu'ils
prennent ils se mettent en danger quoi
il veut pas mettre les gens en danger
c'est pour ça quand c'est des amateurs
comme ça ils veulent pas
juste c'est du spectacle c'est pas du
sport
c'est niveau hyper amateurs
ou des
niveaux ce battle ou tu prends des
risques physiques quoi je sais pas
comment dire c'est normal oui mais c'est
ça en fait
d'ailleurs je rentre dans le rugby
amateur c'est pas tout à fait la même
règle non non
tout ça tu veux pas que les mecs ils se
défoncent
c'est pas tout à fait les mêmes choses
donc c'est normal en fait
ouais bien sûr
de gagner en fait les boxeurs juste ils
participent pas au sport donc au moins
en fait comme c'est populaire ils ont
pas envie de se faire chier
non mais c'est sûr que si tu envoies
taizone
tu la prends une ouverture pour pas
perdre tempo au début il joue quatre
coups il attend et puis il te met KO
direct d'arrêter la box avant même
qu'elle commence là non mais
c'est un exemple comme ça
un vrai boxeur tu peux juste rien faire
quoi non mais je pense que l'arbitre là
il laisse même pas le combat commence en
fait
c'est juste trop dangereux en fait
contre un mec professionnel dans sa
catégorie en fait c'est juste il prend
un coup enfin ouais c'est vraiment
dangereux les gens ils rigolaient le
jour dans le
dans le chat quand je leur disais tu
prends boxeur top c'est juste que il
peut il peut juste mourir en fait c'est
vrai c'est facile déjà là qu'on tramman
il prend quasi un chaos imagine si tu
mets un vrai boxeur en face en fait
c'est tu peux juste mourir enfin premier
degré en fait
c'est pas quoi c'est pas enfin c'est pas
en plus il y a vraiment déjà eu la boxe
des vrais drames quoi alors maintenant
il y a des protocoles et quoi c'est
différent mais dans les vieux combats
dans le passé
bah déjà quand tu prends un KO tu peux
mourir un potentiellement
il va encore tomber malheureusement les
veines
contre un boxeur random ah ouais mais
c'est sûr en fait
il explique les couilles
je crois qu'il a surpris Ikao par ses
clics
qui va arriver
une très belle victoire une victoire
il reprend ses deux points d'avance
probablement très généreux que c'est 10
secondes bah ouais mais non mais c'est
sûr
c'est ce que je disais en fait c'est
juste qu'ils ont fait le sport à
l'envers mais parfois mais ça doit être
des boxeurs pro qui
[Musique]
qui font des échecs à côté parce que tu
aurais le côté de la boxe qui est sympa
quand c'est des pros qui boxe et
sûrement j'imagine que les gens qui
t'a beaucoup de gens sur boxing qui
regarde pas du tout de box mais c'est un
très beau sport et tu as le côté du coup
avec les boxeurs pro qui joue aux échecs
après le côté sa battle ouais les trucs
qui peut tourner sur une pièce de 1 une
gaffe à la con un truc un peu marrant
est-ce que le côté cette battle en box
il est moins flagrant non ou c'est non
mais là tu vois qu'ils sont complètement
nuls mais juste c'est pas drôle
avoir des gens qui savent pas te battre
donc voir des gens qui savent pas jouer
aux échecs c'est marrant mais en fait
voir des gens qui savent pas se battre
comme voir un match de tennis entre toi
et moi quoi enfin bon
non mais ça a aucun tu vois ce que je
veux dire aux échecs c'est drôle les
gens qui jouent mal mais dans le sport
là comme ça c'est pas très amusant quoi
d'accord après bon on voit avec twitch
que finalement
faire de l'audience avec des gens qui
jouent pas très bien certains trucs en
fait il faut mettre des gens connus
ouais c'est la méta maintenant sur les
trucs c'est que tu mets juste des gens
connus qui font un truc et ça enfin ça
marche plus ou moins là tu vas d'un côté
300000 ça c'est impressionnant mais
quand tu as eu des gens connus qui
avaient juste faire un truc de boxe en
espagnol je crois que c'était 900000 ou
un million de personnes qui regardaient
mais c'est plus fun le truc des
Espagnols
parce que c'était deux influenceurs qui
s'aimaient pas du tout
je t'aime pas je m'en fous sur la gueule
enfin je sais pas c'est plus drôle que
du
truc des Espagnols est plus fait kiffer
mais je crois qu'ils étaient bien foutu
sur la gueule en plus
je crois
je crois que c'est un piège d'ouverture
qui va placer et à très heureux
paf c'est le G6 connais pas avec les
Noirs je crois que vous êtes c'est censé
être un coup plus ou moins ça et tu peux
jouer un truc où tu files la tour à 8
mais je sais pas ce que ça donne
non ce qui peut être cool c'est vrai ce
serait alors deux mecs qui s'aiment pas
du tout quoi mais il faut enlever les
casques par contre
mettez déjà allé voir toi en vrai un
vrai combat de boxe non non
en fait ouais c'est non mais c'est en
fait tu t'attends pas quand tu as vu que
à la télé que tu vois en vrai c'est
vraiment violent ou les cookies c'est
je te parle box sans casque et tout
enfin
c'est violent
faut vraiment être courageux pour aller
sur le ring réellement c'est pas
un truc de ouf
ouais c'est un sport
c'est très dur soufre ta main et tu vas
quoi et tu t'en prends plein la gueule
quoi il faut avoir un bon cardio il faut
courageux ou inconsciemment c'est
courageux enfin pourquoi inconscience
enfin c'est un beau sport
mais ouais faut
dans le style rugby pas mal aussi non
franchement c'est plus violent que le
rugby
j'ai déjà vu en vrai mais c'était pas
niveau
jamais de match pro rugby
maintenant c'est vraiment
[Musique]
bon il a défendu
en fait il est vraiment pas mal pour ça
défendre les positions un peu
un peu mal mais pas pas kata quoi je
veux dire mais
ils trouvent sourds de ce top défensif
quoi
normalement il défend vraiment bien mais
ça c'est tellement dur à défendre
au début là quand il a le foutu un peu
enfermé la structure de merde quoi tu
dis il va souffrir et puis je sais pas
il a facilement toutes les changer quoi
il est trop fort
mais je pense que les vannes va quand
même la gagner
dans l'interdie match ça serait pas mal
en tout cas
on espère
un peu vite
et faire des trucs
c'est pas évident
pour essayer de forcer une prise
en fait il y a des quatre
il veut peut-être faire
le roi
OK
du coup je l'épreuve peut-être ça sera
jouable
C3
comme ça j'imagine
c'est à partir de ce moment-là je
l'avais plus ou moins en tête mais ça à
partir de là en fait je comprends pas
comment tu passes
tu es 3D 4 c'est 5
à chaque fois qu'il va t'embêter
[Musique]
pourquoi pas F5 G4 juste que tu mets tes
pions sur blanc
donc c'est des deux et deux grands
il va peut-être faire des six
mais bon robe 4 à 3
à 2
c'est bien joué ça
en F6 une carte de feu
mais je crois que ça gagne ce qui va
gagner des 7
j'ai pas reçu
c'est dans le tempo avec les Blancs sa
petite viennoise il obtient des petits
trucs
deux fois de suite quand même parce que
c'est quand même
comme ouverture après c'est con que il
est ouais qui est le 1 + 1 en fait
à la fin je savais pas franchement tu
peux dire bon il y a un petit monde
le beurette en fait vu quelle vitesse il
y a quelle vitesse le vent clics
tu sens que ça va être dur mais sinon il
est plus ouais
je pensais que ça allait être plus cata
j'ai pas d'air si je change un nom de
Blitz tu as vu la liste ou pas j'ai pas
vu du tout je peux la regarder
c'est vrai qu'il était il était leader
pendant longtemps l'année dernière
je crois pas
il pourrait quoi ce serait pas des
délirants de le voir jouer
en plus de peine j'ai cliqué
ouais non je le vois pas il y a
témie n'est pas Douda mvl GREA ici
martyr aussi
[Musique]
de départ
il y a une animal il y a pas enfin je
l'ai pas vu
guerrier
en doutais
sans clan en brute
et il était de séries combien ce qui
peut jouer contre Carlsen neiman numéro
n'est pas forcément tête de série numéro
1 il est numéro 3 après peut-être qu'il
a sa table fixe
mais après je sais pas combien de
joueurs à liste est complet ils disent
qu'il y a 149 joueurs si c'est ce
forfait tu coupes à 75 donc on a un nom
mais ronde 2 déjà
ce serait beau
donner dès le premier coup une nouvelle
fois enfin
sinon il y a plus aucune cohérence quoi
enfin remarque tu me diras il a rejoint
de tricheurs après et il a jamais rien
dit
et juste en plus il y a beaucoup de
rondes donc il y a peut-être des chances
de jouer plus tard quoi
bon je suis de
retour sur notre partie mais car où il
est encore mieux du coup
il est encore arrivé sur ce truc assez
et un autre truc qui a un truc qui s'est
ouvert sur son ordi ou quoi je l'ai vu
faire une manip bizarre
il est hyper bizarre là il Caro il fait
des grimaces bizarres
il se prend des pop-up peut-être je sais
pas les trucs qui souffrent sur ces
écrans il suit
ça se voit qu'il a fait des trucs au
clavier
maintenant je sais pas ce qui va arriver
exactement mais ouais ça l'a énervé en
tout cas
sur son écran
mais c'est vrai que ça a énervé et tu es
énervé du truc et énervé de la
polyénerver de tout là
alors qu'il est très bien
tout va bien
moi je sais pas je suis étonné
je sais pas
il inscrit pour leur rapide
on va aller voir
non
Kazakhstan c'est pas trop loin de chez
lui quoi il y a quand même champion du
monde bah je sais oui d'autant plus mais
je veux dire il y a pas vraiment le
l'histoire que le déplacement est
compliqué ou quoi là
les voisins quoi
mais ça a complètement déstabilisé
il peut faire un beau tournoi Amazon
bah ouais je pense ça va lui plaire de
jouer après j'imagine si les tournois ou
quand même mieux de pas trop mal partir
parce que c'est très long et si tu es un
peu
c'est un peu mal que dans la salle du
fond dans les derniers effets très très
chiant quoi
je veux dire je sais pas je m'imagine
moi et bon je l'ai jamais joué mais
c'est au début tu as la chance de jouer
des des super joueurs bah ça te fait
plaisir tu fais un bide c'est de faire
un résultat de résultat machin mais tu
commences à perdre une deux machin et
puis après tu tombes contre des bombes
leaders mais tu t'en fous un peu tu
joues plus rien et que tu commences à te
faire arnaquer en plus et compagnie
ça va être très long c'est-à-dire deux
jours
tours
pendant tout le toute cette partie
il devrait gagner une qualité puisqu'il
y a deux tours
ça me paraît tellement bizarre à
première vue je pense qu'il est pas trop
le choix non
j'ai rien dit
pas vu
après
je veux dire bon les noirs sont censés
mieux j'imagine mais ça va pas être
simple quoi
pour rentrer voilà c'est 3 ça couvre
tout ça
[Musique]
il y a peut-être
faut pas tomber quoi
il peut même la perdre parce qu'il est
trop lent
ille un pion qui n'était pas obligé de
perdre
ouais quand il y a peu de temps il fait
n'importe quoi
les tourelles
le truc c'est qu'il fait pas ça en sur
l'échiquier en général je me souviens
les armes ou quoi les trucs chauds qui
jouaient avec peu de temps il donnait
pas tous les pions comme ça quoi ouais
mais c'est vraiment que la souris il a
du mal
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé ce que je
voyais carreaux encore agacé il y a des
trucs qui sont allumés sur son écran
je vois par là à côté
et je sentais agacé pour la partie je
crois qu'ils sont en train de discuter
parents ils disent qu'il y a un problème
de REMAX je sais pas ça discute
il parle à quelqu'un qui parle à
quelqu'un
il y a eu un bug rematch apparemment
mais on le sent agacé
que ce serait plus facile
mais après ça se passe quand même pas
trop mal pour lui mais il est agacé
très clairement regarde
je veux dire ce qui mène de deux points
la cadence qui est censée être la plus
difficile
alors je sais pas si c'est je sais pas
ce que c'était mais
placements boursiers
mais tu as remarqué ou pas qu'est-ce que
le pire fait aujourd'hui quoi
depuis le moment où il a ouvert son truc
à côté regarde comment il est il a
complètement changé d'expression faciale
non mais il était pas comme ça il y a 30
secondes
et les crypto
il y a le VIX quand même qui qui a pas
mal augmenté aujourd'hui donc peut-être
que
je sais pas
non en tout cas c'est étonnant parce que
c'est vraiment enfin en plus il a gagné
la partie enfin il y a tout se passer
bien quoi
il a l'air désespéré quoi
c'est un peu dans la merde apparemment
ah ouais ça ça peut par contre mais ce
serait pas arrivé là maintenant il y a
une news binance qui est sortie genre en
mode bidon se ferme
ok parce que ça ça peut faire suer
non mais vraiment tu as l'impression
qu'il est arrivé un truc quoi
malgré tout
c'était un petit peu un peu plus
renseigné il aurait pu sentir quand même
la merde arriver quoi c'est bizarre et
Caro appelle-moi frère la prochaine fois
non mais bon je pense que il y a du tout
mettre sur des wallet
il a pas dû laisser là dessus
on saura pas mais je suis curieux
il aime bien faire ça non mais il a
vraiment enfin moi en fait je vois les
écrans de sécurité du coup il y a
vraiment d'un truc qui a pop-up sur son
écran il a vraiment utilisé des des
raccourcis clavier pour le fermer ou
pour l'ouvrir je sais pas pourquoi
[ __ ] mais il a vraiment vu une autre
page internet
donc il a vraiment eu accès à une
information et depuis ce moment là
c'est pas juste fait cette tête pendant
une partie où il oublie un coup je sais
pas quoi
non non et puis il faisait son truc avec
la main là comme ça genre énervé et tout
quand il avait un moment où il a eu sa
page à un moment donné quand j'ai vu
qu'il a fait son truc il a fait cette
main énervée quoi
se faire accuser triche à cause de ça
non après normalement oui là il aurait
dû perdre la partie par forfait parce
que tu dois pas avoir le droit de
naviguer sur une autre page juste par
principe mais bon ça après tout le monde
fait ce qu'il veut donc c'est pas grave
mais c'est sûr que c'est pas ça
on est loin d'une réalité bien triste
l'annonce d'un décès
je pense pas si tu as quelqu'un de
proche qui qui meurt et que
je suis continué à jouer ou quoi c'est
oui
je sais pas mais c'était il a l'air de
s'être remis mais ça lui a
l'espace d'un instant il est il était
autre part
et encore plus sa petite qualité pour
les puntos
ce qui leur permet de jouer a priori
ça a dur de passer sur case noire
ils sont bloqués pour l'instant
tu ramènes le fou en B1
plus ou moins
mais oui
pas à calculer pourquoi ça marchait pas
non plus
après là il est un peu bloqué
mais ok
mais
quand même
ouais enfin tu as quand même ce [ __ ]
de réseau de maths qui peut
c'est bien joué je pense d'un
coup qui donne envie ça sent bon
contrôler ta méfie 4 et
c'est deux ça devrait être pas trop
mauvais
j'imagine c'est ce qu'il devait le faire
chier d'où tombait
[Musique]
j'ai 5
ou tu
peux aussi faire tourner peut-être
je sais pas qui va
partir
et d'un processus tu veux quoi ah [ __ ]
[Musique]
OK
va savoir
gagner pour les blancs
c'est pas simple pendant peut-être j'ai
cinq dmg4 pour faire du Tours il a fait
tourner 7 il attaque des 5
peut-être
c'est la même chose quoi
je crois qu'il s'est trompé
je crois qu'il va se faire [ __ ]
il me fait chier là les Van il va perdre
non
je sais pas ce qu'il faut
c'est terrible attends
est-ce que les deux dernières parties
enfin en fait c'est 2-0 Naka je suis sûr
sur un vrai échiquier c'est de zéro
Levan mais c'est une trouvaille
mais bon j'ai au lieu de 4 enfin au lieu
de 4,5
et en belette ça va être encore pire il
a l'air
mais comment il a raté ça
c'était complètement gagnant ouais c'est
c'est
pas tu t'en fous de ton tour
tu vas pas perdre ça non
en fait
il y a trop de pions de merde quoi mais
il a pas été gagné un moment il faisait
pas fou des quatre
à la fin
deux trois fois avant la fin si en fait
d'accueil s'auto clou non là ça te fait
pas [ __ ]
c'est tellement logique
ment
et c'est dans ces quatre la connerie
en fait
ah [ __ ] c'est beau
même en longue pas facile d'ailleurs si
tu as peu de temps
de loin c'est pas facile ça
joli
très jolie d'amour
ça c'est joli
[Musique]
il a pris le large
mais bon c'est comme ça
ouais
après bon c'était un peu annoncé
malheureusement enfin scénario redouté
mais
dont on se doutait
plus serré que prévu mais bon enfin de
toute façon ça change rien en fait
non
quelque parties sympas un peu d'émotion
mais maintenant
ça risque de ouais de dérouler un peu
malheureusement
oh bah ça déroulé déjà complètement
avant
mais ça va encore plus dérouler mais moi
en plus elle est partie là les deux
dernières en fait
plus on va avancer et puis les cadences
votre favorable
et donc
le chaos dans le chaos c'est pas un
chaos mais
je sais pas
tu peux le voir où enfin
ça me fait rire en fait
ça me bute en fait
c'est grand
[Musique]
sur WhatsApp sur
où tu veux ça me bute vraiment
on va sur Messenger
[Musique]
je crois que c'est 10 minutes la pause
en fait
et du coup Amane pas mal ou bon pas
spécialement regarde hein ça me bute
je crois c'était la première
le combat là-dessus quoi mais ouais
normal en fait
il y a 5 minutes aujourd'hui l'autre
jour c'était dit ça c'est sûr
alors la technique du la technique de
vote en fait ça me pique
c'est exceptionnel
et tu sens qu'il veut essayer de
s'extraire de
quoi en fait ça doit pas être facile
tatouage je pense tu les défonces les
dehors
en fait
le repasse deux fois plus c'est beau
quoi en fait
ça c'est
très chaud quoi
de faire le maçon de Cornetto quoi
en fait je vois que le gros point fort
d'avance qui s'en foutait de prendre des
coups
de mon père qui était boxeur
professionnel mais je l'avais vu
que le plus important c'était de mettre
des coups et de savoir en prendre en
fait et je crois que ceux qui enfin
quand tu es nul d'autant plus tu vas
vraiment pas prendre de coup ça doit
être dur tu fais comme Rocky quoi tu
t'en fous de prendre des coups
mais au truc ça va être dur de boxer
contre quelqu'un que tu détestes pas
tout le monde
quelqu'un de lambda je serais incapable
d'aller boxer ouais bon c'est le temps
du combat en fait enfin tu n'en veux
même pas quoi c'est juste tu te bats et
puis après le match est fini je pense
j'y arriverai pas franchement j'y
arriverai pas
genre premier degré j'y arriverai pas
j'arriverai pas à mettre des coups à
quelqu'un que
c'est pas facile
ils arrêtent le combat dès que tu te
prends un coup
non mais je pense après tu fais la part
des choses enfin ok pendant le match
c'est le match et que c'est fini c'est
fini d'aller prendre un verre
bah oui et non parce que tu peux
vraiment faire le mec il peut vraiment
mal finir
ouais non mais j'en ai tous conscients
des risques si on fait ça quoi je veux
dire
je suis pas sûr je suis pas méchamment
quoi en fait c'est juste on doit
combattre au combat quoi non mais là je
pense surtout qu'ils étaient conscient
que ça arrêtait au moindre micro
problème oui oui non mais je parle de
combat
tu revois les combats de Mohamed Ali
c'est
le match de ouf c'était contre format le
fameux
mais c'était fou le déplace le
déplacement et les esquives de Mohamed
Ali jamais vu ça en fait je comprends
même pas comment c'est possible
ils veulent comme un papillon quoi
non mais c'est impressionnant
comme une abeille
aussi
je sais pas j'ai pas vu moi j'ai regardé
deux trois trucs c'était pour me faire
un avis et c'est quoi c'est les arbitres
qui ont donné la victoire ou c'est fini
qu'ils ont arrêté c'est fini sur échec
et mat mais en fait à la bonne toutes
les 15 secondes ou les 10 secondes
l'arbitre il arrêtait ah il a jamais
arrêté le combat non Justine entre mais
bon
du coup oui si tu enlèves 80% du temps
de boxe
[Musique]
la box elle a un bon niveau en fait
mais elle savait beau que ça avant ou
c'est juste si elle s'entraîner et puis
c'est entraîner c'est vraiment plus
forte à la boxe mais après vraiment
moins forte aux échecs mais en fait si
tu es plus fort à la boxe c'est enfin
box car quoi
non mais faut vraiment juste prendre des
boxeurs professionnels en fait et tu vas
avoir un vrai truc
du cardio elle frappe ouais non non elle
est vraiment forte
non mais je veux dire après oui on peut
pas te
elle est plus forte
on va pas arrêter de bosser
après c'est pas facile le truc amateur
comme ça quand tu veux pas que les gens
se blessent et tout c'est pas facile
arbitrer
c'est quand même plus du spectacle que
du sport donc c'est pas évident quoi
ouais mais du coup fin si tu peux pas
jouer le jeu c'est quoi l'intérêt quoi
alors ça j'en sais rien mais en gros je
comprends pourquoi l'arbitre arbitré
comme ça c'est ce que je voulais dire
vrai qu'elle est l'intérêt ça c'est ça
me dépasse mais
mais en vrai la décision de l'arbitre
elle me ouais enfin je comprends
pourquoi c'est comme ça
soit
un enjeu tu vois enfin tant pis enfin au
pire là c'est un spectacle il y avait
zéro en jeu l'arbitrate le combat il dit
ouais bon bah elle a gagné enfin puis
c'est fini enfin
c'est juste un spectacle il y a rien à
commander alors face peu importe oui
c'est ça on s'en fout
mais oui je préfère le catch en fait
dans ce même dans ce même style quoi
l'Undertaker quoi
il est bien mais bon il a plus de temps
quoi
j'ai l'impression qu'on va voir ce
scénario tout le long quoi bon au moins
il a avoir des bonnes positions
mais malheureusement
vous prend des cinq étoiles
de s'incruster un peu doubler les tours
de faire deux trois trucs
des deux faire ces quatre un jour
il est très heureux
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression qu'il gagne tout
je mange un petit truc
ok donc
cette petite finale je sais pas il se
fait un pion passé c'est étant de le
pousser les petits jouent des 7 pour le
stopper
et il recycle cavalier en B1 pour lancer
3 éventuellement attaquer des cinq c'est
mieux pour les blancs ça non
je sais pas moi
bonjour c'est censé être un statu quo à
la position mais
ça peut tomber
peut-être je sais pas
c'est 5 BK
et là c'était drôle le statut pour le
coup
[Musique]
ça risque de juste répéter
la partie suivante
en fait
son espèce de vie
donc il est ici une fois qu'il est ici
une fois qu'il prend 4
il est déjà un peu comme ça
et c'est 6 des trois je crois
non
c'est pas un mauvais setup pour les
blancs
alors moi non mais
j'ai vu
j'ai vu des parties là dessus
c'était pas comme ça
et puis on prend qu'elle prend et je
sais pas c'est rock F4 direct
bon du coup bon là ça se passe pas trop
mal pour les carreaux je veux dire
pas trop de problèmes pour lui quoi
une structure ou quoi que ce soit
boxing alors je sais pas je pense qu'il
y a un KO technique c'est perdu mais bon
je n'ai pas bien les règles donc
j'imagine quoi
ok du coup F4 ici d'échanger les fous je
sais pas
il faut 5 c'est un coup
[Musique]
direct après l'ouverture
depuis un moment
bizarre
non mais vraiment
tu sais pas c'est pénible la défendre
avec les Noirs quoi
il joue pas très bien il est un peu
dominé mais dur à battre
elle a vraiment fait la différence sur
le clic quand même
en général
mais vraiment là tu fais le même match
sur un vrai échiquier c'est pas le même
score du tout
recettes
ok
mais en fait tu as gagné
du coup du coup du coup ce qui est un
mémoire qu'on aura un peu plus faible il
va tenter de contre-attaquer sur G2
pas mal son choix mais assez bizarre sur
le coup mais si l'obtient ça
c'était il a plus de chance que que la
finale de tour avec la tour septième et
un purement
ouais en fait l'ordi dans les fous
prends H6 gagnant
c'est chiant c'est toujours le même
scénario quoi un moment désolé ouais ça
a pas mis les pieds du bon côté et Caro
il a les Noirs désolé pour les gens qui
suivent on n'a pas eu le truc
j'ai pas regardé
ce qui suivent les matchs on a bien
compris parce que les couleurs changent
mais ça a pas fait tourner les chéquiers
bon ben
qu'on l'arrête
pas mais ce que j'ai dit il va se faire
tomber entre guillemets
le scénario en boucle pendant 4 heures
c'était
le pronostic devant match quoi qu'il en
soit donc
un gars qui domine les ouvertures
s'équilibrées d'un joueur qui domine le
milieu tu as l'autre qui domine la fin
quoi
que ça joue un peu arnaque mais ça se
joue aussi un peu au clic
c'est un peu le problème de base sur
Internet
et c'est comme ça enfin c'est une
nouvelle discipline ou faut accepter ça
et il faut
quand tu es pas bon faut graisser
là-dessus quoi
oui tu as des joueurs qui ont progressé
mais je veux dire que les bonnes nuits
il est vraiment loin de enfin il s'en
fout quoi je crois qu'il joue jamais en
fait il fait jamais un title il fait
jamais rien
donc il y a pas un niveau minimum de
clic quoi
mais oui mais du coup enfin j'imagine
que c'était un vrai objectif il essaiera
mais là je pense qu'il essaie pas quoi
enfin il fait de son mieux pour cette
bien joué aux échecs et puis bon bah à
la fin quand ça se joue au clic bah il
sait pas faire quoi et puis voilà et
puis c'est comme ça quoi
complètement
je suis un peu quoi
c'est un super joueur d'échec en fait
donc il va jouer des bons coups mais
en fait quand on fasse c'est très fort
aussi et c'est quand même très fort
aussi bah il faut bien que la différence
se fasse quelque part il y a une telle
différence dans justement cette vitesse
d'exécution et elle fait de faire tomber
l'adversaire les arnaques machin que
ça ça fait une grosse diff quoi sur le
match quoi il y a quand même beaucoup de
parties qui se sont joués à ça où ils
étaient bien et j'arrivais 20 secondes
chacun ou je sais pas quoi et puis il
perd quoi
ouais c'est ça
et beaucoup de parties qui sont joueurs
mais qui sont
dans le même sens
donc le contenu il a pas du tout à
rougir sa prestation après bah ouais le
score va être lourd a priori et puis
voilà quoi
après faut dire kikao de base est aussi
un peu meilleur en blitz que les Vans
donc ça lui rajoute un avantage quoi
bizarre cette position je trouve oui
c'est un peu bizarre son cité 3 tout ça
mais c'est pas con ce qui fait en fait
il essaie de stabiliser il a créé des
pions doubler adversaire et il essaie
d'ouvrir la belle dame créer une
faiblesse là-bas
après c'est pas le genre de position on
a l'habitude de voir
je sais pas j'aurais tendance à préférer
les Noirs mais sans trop de conviction
je sais pas trop
très beau que les vannes remontent en
belette
il va nous faire un coup spécial
on peut faire tomber 4 après du coup
il attaque des deux non
pas
mais bon c'est bizarre je pense
ramener la tour en E5 catac
lysé
bien joué ça tu fais toujours des petits
coups inattendus à la con comme ça pas
mal
moi je pensais plutôt que de ramener le
roi vers le 1 défendre des deux libérer
la tour mais bon il a fait beaucoup plus
rapide quoi
directement partie des fonds de
cavaliers pour libérer le pion a la
grande force
on va couper aussi c'est pas mal
ça tombe comme des petits pains tout ça
quoi
terminé encore non mais bon
je pense
ça fait 8 3
ouais ça fait un long moment comme tu
dis
OK
avec les Blancs là dessus mais
bon
comme toi mais bon
il faut combien il y a
je sais pas quoi mais
il y a pas quoi
du coup j'ai une que les Blancs d'être
un peu mieux là quand même mais bon
il
[Musique]
est beaucoup plus normal quoi
selon ce standards
la Bourse est repartie à la hausse
voilà des bonnes nouvelles
c'est moi qui suis malade
en pleine forme
aujourd'hui ça a l'air
les gastro c'est ça c'est 24 48 heures
généralement mais par contre tu es
vraiment très mal
et ouais le crapaud celui qui perd
éliminer exactement c'est un tournoi
c'est un tableau c'est élimination
directe
là c'est le quart de finale comme tu
peux le voir en
Kiko
[Musique]
il y a eu Carson mais qui mais c'est
Maxime qui l'avait
on a un problème
c'est pas si fort et que là il y a mieux
je sais pas mais
je dirais ça mais je suis pas sûr
déjà depuis 2017 ce truc ça fait déjà
longtemps
à 2016-2017 ok je pensais que c'était
genre
2016-2018
il y a déjà 2016 aussi OK
c'est trop de faire autant de grimaces
quand même
la fin du monde encore quoi
c'est une habitude en fait c'est devenu
une habitude je sais pas c'est comme un
toc quoi maintenant faire des grimaces à
la con c'est au début il le faisait pour
s'amuser ou quoi et maintenant
non ça sort tout seul quoi
il y a parfois ah non il y a pas
dans un mois j'aurais pu rien à [ __ ]
franchement j'ai pas de temps à perdre
avec ça
j'ai juste plus important dans ma life
que
j'ai tapé sur la tête à Gotham non mais
en plus il s'est enfin tu vois ça me
frustre d'autant plus si l'arbitre il
arrête aussi vite le combat ça
m'intéresse vraiment pas tu vois
mais vraiment non mais ça a aucun
intérêt
tu veux je fais arbitre non mais tu vois
si c'est un arbitrage normal pourquoi
pas mais non mais j'ai vraiment pas de
temps à perdre mais là avec un arbitrage
comme ça c'est juste que ça ça
m'intéresse pas
le truc arrête OK
ça n'a aucun intérêt
petite nul
ça répète mais pas trop
Caro qui fait n'importe quoi
on fait n'importe quoi toute la partie
en plus un moment il était repassé
plutôt pas trop mal puis au pire nul
c'est la vie et en fait il veut
de la joue quoi
non
mais bon sur un petit point de prix
tu sais pas dangereux justement quoi
c'est pas drôle
je crois il mesure combien gagne un
mètre 68 ou 1 m 70 peut-être je sais pas
aucune idée
je vais commencer à prendre des trucs
tous les jours enfin ouais mais bon
après c'est juste faut pas que l'arbitre
il arrête c'est tout quoi on s'est garé
je veux bien le faire mais si l'arbitre
il arrête ça m'intéresse pas
c'est sûr que je si je le faisais je me
chargeais et puis oui il fait un mais
oui j'ai d'autres objectifs que ce
qu'ils ont fait là
que moi en fait faudrait que personne
nous a voulu pour l'autre pour le truc
là à Los Angeles et tout on avait
proposé Fab
mais je sais pas si non pris au sérieux
enfin c'est juste qu'en fait ils ont
compris qu'on était pas du tout dans le
même mood
si on va combattre on va combattre quoi
qu'on était pas du tout dans le même
mode
ce qui nous a coûté en fait
[Rires]
j'arrête moi j'arrête pas
ça mais c'est la vie quoi j'en sais rien
moi je sais pas du tout j'ai jamais boxé
donc
je crois que je peux tenir 40 secondes
pour te connaître un peu je pense que
toi tu aurais été vraiment très fort
ah bah genre
[Musique]
le truc les gens ne savent pas mais en
fait FAP et quelqu'un qui ne ressent pas
la douleur
non mais c'est il est très très dur au
Mali donc en fait Fab c'est
enfin il aurait fait comme un man il
aurait accepté de prendre des coups sauf
qu'en fait amen il aurait été ko après
le premier coup de femme enfin c'est
ouais
en fait c'est ouais
c'est une question de gabarit ah ouais
non mais en plus Fabi fait peut-être 60
kg de plus Kaman quoi
donc ouais c'est ça
je suis fort que toi
enfin bon ça aurait pu faire un beau
combat
dans la discuté dans le train avec avec
Baki du chasse boxing
et on n'a pas trouvé un seul match up
intéressant en fait après discussion
non mais c'est vraiment à discuter avec
ce qui pourrait être intéressant comme
combat et puis après une discussion
d'une demi-heure avec aucun en fait
non mais on voulait parler entre joueurs
d'échec pro
et en fait tu as pas de combat possible
Jobs qui ferme peut-être la compétition
juste
je sais pas si une hélice un dépôt
il voudra jamais faire
ah mais bon
très chaud aussi pour aller mais en fait
le problème à la boxe et aux échecs déjà
qu'il est fort hein
du coup ça ferme juste la possibilité de
faire du coup ça a aucun intérêt
parce qu'en fait non à la boxe et aux
échecs
c'est un problème en fait
quand un mec qui fait du sport de combat
depuis gamin et qu'il est 27 20
il fait vraiment de la boxe
aussi potentiellement
là il ferme un peu le sport en fait
je pense il serait très ténieux quoi
mais je sais pas s'il a une bonne
motricité par contre
[Musique]
je sais pas
de prendre des coups aussi
une petite pause à la pause bon ça c'est
très très facilement
contre Mazet s'arrêter
il fait un 90 non
90 90
oui non mais
j'arrive et bien pour faire du tennis tu
dis ouais c'est le gabarit quoi
et après on serait peut-être pas mal
d'ailleurs pendant des chaises
mais en gros ouais aussi ouais c'est
vraiment la capacité à vouloir prendre
des coups c'est vraiment
hyper important
et niche ça donne quoi
mais j'ai pas compris là je crois que
l'an prochain il va le refaire un truc
ils veulent faire Gotham contre Eric
Rosen
donc
je comprends pas en fait
voici le fond vraiment je comprends pas
en fait ah mais bon a priori il y a pas
trop d'intérêt
ils font ce qu'ils ont envie de faire
quoi
mais ouais je pense faudrait faire un
truc avec Carlsen contre Nima en fait
faut des trucs plus c'est un beau truc
vraiment des faut arrêter de faire un
truc de de gens qui s'entendent plus ou
moins ou j'en sais rien truc de délire
d'influenceur échec ou j'en sais rien
faut vraiment faire des vrais trucs qui
se détestent quoi
mais je pense qu'il peut pas accepter
quoi
mais ça ouais ce serait beaucoup bas
tre j'en sais rien moi aussi
ça peut être beau aussi
pas de la box c'est un truc un peu de
vouloir
il faisait des bons et tout il était
très esthétique
de sport
non mais ce qui est triste ce dont j'ai
souvent parlé sur sur les streams c'est
que maintenant quel que soit les sports
ou quoi bon mis à part les trucs que
font IP la télé comme le foot ou quoi ou
ils font vraiment full pour faire hype
mais sinon en fait il vaut mieux
faire une compétition entre influenceur
qui est entre professionnels et je
trouve ça tellement dommage
en terme de vue ouais
termes de visibilité en vrai
c'est vraiment devenu la mode
c'est deux trois dernières années même
peut-être un peu plus 5 6 c'est pour ça
que même un match de POC j'aime fera
plus qu'un match de championnat du monde
enfin
oui ce qui est terrible en fait je
trouve ça ridicule en fait mais ça vient
des gens qui regardent
et incroyable ouais mais un match de
Pocket que les candidats par exemple
réellement
et encore t'avais pas forcément les
streamers les plus connus du monde sur
le Top Chef et le format était pas fait
pour faire hype parce que les gens
étaient chez eux et tout c'est une
petite progression
on trouve une petite production par
contre pardon
mais après est-ce que tu penses c'est
parce que c'est genre exceptionnel enfin
c'est rare qu'un pot de chemmp et s'il y
avait une saison de poockshion ça
marcherait quand même ou sinon
quoi qu'il fasse ça marche donc s'il y
avait une saison pop-champ avec toujours
les mêmes influenceurs qui font des
échecs peut-être pas en fait genre si
l'influenceur en question il fait un
truc d'échec puis après un truc de box
puis après un truc de tennis puis après
un truc de fou et tout ça marchera
toujours alors que ça c'est un truc non
générations ça aurait pas fait enfin
vous avez pas enfin ouais j'aurais pas
regardé enfin d'ailleurs je regarde pas
mais
les trucs les trucs influenceurs ça
marche
ça marche vraiment bien
non mais bon
pourquoi si tu es très pressé
déjà en France
du match est entendu j'ai envie de dire
on a une partie
et du coup il dure combien de temps la
session de 3 + 1h c'est une heure donc
une belle petite pause et après une
bullette mais sans pause
l'important
la messe est dites bonne nuit bonne nuit
à toi mais tu avais pas besoin de temps
à 21h elle était déjà dit tout à l'heure
[Musique]
il est content de tenir avec les Noirs
après tu l'offres une opportunité il va
jouer mais
en gros non il peut faire de la Clément
il va faire nul quoi
je sais pas il doit une option qui met
du flou
qui explique ce côté là
c'est bien
ouais
j'ai pas touché alors je sais pas
pourquoi elle fait ça mais
oui c'est sur discord
voilà
ça a l'air d'aller encore au noir
les vannes on croyait voir la SS enfin
c'est pas pour dire mais
ça joue quand même mieux que les
perd contre régional non ce moment
il y a pas un match amical
catastrophique qui a été perdu là il y a
pas longtemps non ils ont gagné la con
de Grenoble en match amical mais
[Musique]
en fait face c'est vous ou quoi tout
heureusement qu'il y a encore y aller
l'équipe de France qui te sauve sinon
tout ce que tout ça quoi tu touches
c'est cata quoi ça va pas du tout
ça
a été on va aller en National enfin je
comprends plus ce qui se passe quoi
quand même pas en National non ça va se
maintenir
qui arrive
quand même les bonnes
faut prendre ça au sérieux je te dis pas
que c'est sûr pour l'instant on est pour
l'instant on est arrivé quoi mais il y a
c'est encore pas mal de journées on est
même pas mis championnat ils ont le
droit de faire un mercato de modifier
deux trois trucs surface financière
normalement plus plus grosse que
d'autres équipes de Ligue 2 mais pas
faut que je enfin je sais pas faire ça
change un peu quoi que ça joue mieux
[Musique]
c'est sur quelle chaîne après tu
regardes les matchs je sais pas si on
peut les voir enfin compliqué quoi et tu
vas être su non
j'ai jamais connu ça j'ai déjà connu la
Ligue 2 j'ai déjà connu les baffons de
la Ligue 2 mais bon c'était sauvé mais
tu écoutes sur quelle radio
je sais pas peut-être il y aura du
France Bleu régional
il a encore perdu une pièce les
lettres
à la fin
terrible
pour les Vans
il a imposé
il y a encore une bonne heure à jouer
quand même
ça fait plaisir
dans le studio mais bon après je suis en
pull quoi
économie d'électricité pourtant moi
aussi je veux un truc bien je sais pas
c'est un truc
qui tient chaud
qu'est-ce que c'est long ces matchs
quand même
ouais j'avais oublié un peu un an que je
n'ai pas fait
ah puis la petite pause elle est sympa
aussi au milieu ça c'est une nouveauté
bon finalement ce n'est pas si mal
sortie
ils ont le droit d'abandonner ouais à
partir de 10 minutes enfin 10 minutes de
la fin du match ils ont le droit
d'abandonner ouais mais bon
dans les parties que
10 minutes de la fin tu as plus lucidité
tu fais que cliquer quoi
mais là il va peut-être finalement
gagner
pas mal retourner les choses les bons
quand même comment parfois sur certaines
game
on voit le facteur chance entre
guillemets
il va revenir à 5 points
ce facteur très aimé des ambulants en ce
moment ouais
ils ont tellement le SAM les Anglais
c'est terrible en fait
je pense qu'ils font un match avec les
Belges en fait
je sais pas ils disent qu'on a eu de la
chance moi j'ai pas vu le match mais bon
non mais en fait ils ont bien joué les
Anglais déjà bravo mais
comment dire
mais pourquoi pas abandonner
non le match en fait oui non ils ont
très bien joué ils ont été durs mais en
fait ils se sont pas trop arrivés à se
créer de méga occasion quoi
il en peut pas dire on met la tête
gagner ou quoi enfin c'était chaud oui
tu peux gagner tu peux perdre tu peux
arriver et après évidemment raté le
deuxième penalty bon ok c'est un cadeau
mais de base m'arriver enfin c'est juste
une faute complètement débile sur un
ballon qui a loué tout le monde enfin tu
fais pas faute c'est pareil quoi ça va
tellement à rien
donc c'est un peu un penalty qui tombe
du ciel c'est pas genre il y avait un
face à face et ok il le faut chez il y a
penalty et il rate le penalty c'est un
truc ça me fait de jeu quoi mais donc je
sais pas en fait oui le match mais ou
pas enfin d'ailleurs bah voilà c'est ce
qui s'est passé mais il y a pas en faire
tout un drame
ça arrive quoi mais les penalties y
étaient
oui
le premier bon ok c'est la vie c'est une
vraie faute mais tu peux comprendre le
mec il fait des dributions
[Musique]
en fait c'est juste un c'est même pas un
centre c'est un long ballon de vent qui
passe au dessus de tout le monde c'est
fini je sais pas il y en a qui arrive
qui charge dans le domaine
ça a raison enfin ouais mais il a craqué
qu'en fait mais du coup bah penalty mais
genre c'est pas là c'était pareil ça
devait tout le monde ça fait rien quoi
et
voilà donc là aussi ça c'est le coup de
chance mais bon quand bien même il aura
mis ok son penalty avec deux quoi enfin
tu peux pas présumer tout ce qui va se
passer peut-être 3 2 peut-être il y a
une séance de tir au mieux donc
c'était vraiment la beauté du format ce
que je viens de suivre là
et contre le Maroc tu penses qu'on est
favori gros ou c'est chaud
ouais on est favoris gros mais toi tu as
vu tous les matchs
en fait le truc c'est qu'ils prennent
pas de but le Maroc donc c'est compliqué
de gagner quoi enfin ils sont
en fait ils ont pris un but depuis le
début de la compétition ils l'ont mis
contre leur camp contre le Canada quoi
ils ont pas pris de but toute la
Belgique pas de prix depuis toute
l'Espagne près de but contre le Portugal
donc c'est quand même une performance
incroyable après
bon tu te dis ok ils vont peut-être pas
refaire le coup à chaque fois il
commence à avoir pas mal de blessés en
plus le mec qui ont des petits pépins
physiques et
il y a donc en soit normalement oui
France gros favori mais bon s'il refont
une performance sur ce calibre là ça
sera pas simple
mais ils ont des joueurs connus de
premier plan
quelques-uns
de Séville après il y a boufal alors bon
c'est un peu moins fort mais il était
très bien quand il était à Lille et en
France en Ligue 1
ils ont misera oui mais il est un peu
blessé c'est un mec qui joue au Bayern
ça fait quelques beaux joueurs quand
même tout ça et après ton dégâts moins
connus j'avais un gars au milieu je sais
plus comment il s'appelle un chauve là
qui joue en Italie il est hyper bon
les défenseurs ils sont solides après
mais oui c'est pas des grands noms quoi
et
oui sur le papier tu dis oui France
beaucoup plus forte mais ils sont très
cohérents dans ce qu'ils font ils sont
solides ils sont solidaires et ils se
font pas de fautes de concentration
ils sont pas donc écoute on va voir mais
bon tu te dis que ok à un moment
peut-être ils vont finir par craquer
quoi enfin et puis bon la France peut
aussi te faire des différences avec du
Mbappé des Giroud qui en forme
plutôt favoris mais c'est pas gagné
d'avance en tout cas enfin faut pas
partir là-dessus sinon c'est la
désillusion quoi en général
ils croient assez Argentine
doit être plus forte mais bon les
crottes ils sont ils sont solides c'est
un peu le même genre en fait les crottes
ils essaient de pas prendre de but ils
en prennent très peu
et ils sont solidaires enfin c'est voilà
c'est pas du magnifique football mais
ils sont ils sont chiants à jouer quoi
la Croatie du rabattre ça refait une
finale France Croatie
non mais en fait
elle est croate limite favoris je veux
dire je sais pas
c'est très énervé des Argentins aussi
j'étais obligé de te troll quand même
surtout
il était très beau
ils sont bien dans leur match et en fait
ils décident de pourrir le match sans
raison et du coup ça dégénère vraiment
quoi en fait mais ils l'ont vraiment
pourri le match à un point où
et
après ouais bon c'était les mecs se
détestaient ça failli partir en général
deux trois fois enfin c'était c'était
stable quoi comme ambiance mais ils ont
vraiment créé le truc de nulle part
juste tu t'en fous quoi puis ton match
il y a de zéro pierre de un et ça va
bah si je le connais mais je veux dire
autant tu vois il y aurait 0-0 et il
veut faire tilter l'adversaire mais là
tu mets deux zéro tu as pas enfin
cherche pas à faire
fini ton match et puis ça va aller mais
par Eden c'est pas ça genre tout le
temps tout le temps il faut
mais c'est un con fini ou bah je crois
moi je l'aime pas mais après
mais écoute il doit pas être si mal
enfin je veux dire c'est déjà parlé de
la prime maintenant il avait la Juve
enfin il fait pas des clubs horribles
enfin
c'est à dire que j'imagine c'est que le
blog doit lui trouver un intérêt quoi
il était pas comme ça quoi
non mais il y a toujours
sur là mais c'est un gagnant mais enfin
l'autre paresse c'est un
en fait il a fait un truc j'ai jamais vu
de tout faire ça quoi en fait il fait un
énorme taxe déjà il peut se prendre
rouge peut-être mais bon
et en fait dans la foulée il dégage le
ballon mais de toutes ses forces sur le
banc de touche mais je sais enfin mais
je sais pas pourquoi tu as fait ce que
je veux dire il est juste débile quoi en
fait mais après je crois que
je crois que les Hollandais était aussi
bien débile mais bon après du coup tout
le monde devenait complètement débile
enfin après si jamais vraiment qui a
commencé ces trucs là ça m'a donné
l'impression que c'est les Argentins
mais peut-être je me trompe peut-être en
fait c'était les autres et lui du coup
mais bon bref voilà donc oui pour leur
attitude mais mais bon après ils ont ce
Grinda en eux ils sont ils sont où quoi
non plus il comprend jamais tu le
reproches tu te regardes non enfin c'est
normal oui
bon bref voilà donc oui non les
Argentins
je sais pas en fait ouais il
m'impressionne pas trop mais
il gagne ils vont tout donner quoi
bien dans sa coupe du monde
[Musique]
donc du radiateur en fait
ce serait une belle finale en vrai
ouais après je sais pas si je serai si
beau en soi enfin mais c'est une belle
fille belle affiche franchement France
ouais mais c'est
enfin
on a fait une fois
non on va pas à chaque fois faire France
Croatie fin tu vois c'est
hyper improbable mais là maintenant
il y a des chances
le match de la Coupe du Monde enfin
c'est dans le même groupe ouais mais ce
serait une première victoire en Coupe du
monde pour une deuxième pas besoin je
préfère une troisième
[Musique]
mais du coup la poule de la poule de la
Belgique était pas si faible en fait du
tout c'est très fort toi
et le Canada jouait pas mal elle est
belge il faut pas mal enfin bon là ils
vont bien qu'est-ce qu'ils ont eu fait
mais c'est une belle équipe quoi il doit
avoir d'autant plus le SAM non
ils sont mal tombés quoi dans la poule
et après peut-être une autre poule
serait pas passé non plus j'ai
l'impression que c'était pas la belle
entente dans le groupe et que les gars
étaient vieillissant quoi qu'il en soit
mais ils étaient pas loin de passer non
dans le dernier match ils étaient pas
loin de marquer il y a pas lukaraté des
trucs un peu
complètement prêt bon peut-être tu
marques tu te fais égaliser enfin j'en
sais rien si
non non mais c'était pas si loin ils ont
pas été ridicule
mais disons ils ont galéré à fond pour
battre le Canada
le Maroc alors sur le coup tu prends ça
pour une grosse surprise mais vu la
Coupe du Monde qui font en fait c'est un
désordre et dans les matchs ils font nul
contre la Croatie en 2001 quoi donc oui
faites 20
avec leur recul tu dis ouais bon bah pas
de chance c'est la vie mais
ouais pas de bol
donc la finale c'est dimanche au final
c'est dimanche
une mardi mercredi
c'est cohérent et
ils essaient de piquer quand ils peuvent
ils font ils ressortent pas mal les
ballons et
il joue vraiment avec leurs armes ils
optimisent à fond quoi
un bilan en fait parce que bon le
troisième match contre la France
un peu un match qui compte pour rien
côté français ils ont fait tourner à
fond avec vraiment l'équipe B quoi et
avant ça
ça aurait pu mieux rigoler enfin c'est
comme ça mais ils ont après deux matchs
plus ou moins éliminé quoi
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont semi roue
libre
mais ça suffit il garde son plus 5 pour
l'instant
tu es arrivé
on disait qu'on irait pas loin
maintenant tout le monde dit qu'on va
gagner
bah ouais ça qu'avant la Coupe du Monde
c'est dur d'être méga optimiste on va tu
dis ok on a effectivement pas mal mais
ça c'est pas trop bien passé les
derniers matchs Danemark ou quand même
ça fait peur quoi tu te fais rouler
dessus
tu arrives là tu as plein de joueurs
forfaits qui se blessent que machin ça
sent pas hyper bon quoi
puis en fait ça joue pas mal ça sourit
puis tu vois les autres matchs sur les
autres équipes en fait tu te dis que tu
es pas moins fort c'est pas forcément
dire que tu es vraiment meilleur par
exemple les Anglais je pense pas qu'on
s'améliore les Anglais mais je veux dire
enfin voilà 55 ans quoi
etc et là ça peut gagner quoi
mais ça veut pas dire ça va gagner ça
peut ça peut perdre des fois à la fin
peu importe mais il y a vraiment une
chance
c'est c'est pas du tout improbable des
logos
on a la réussite il faut dire quand même
ça se passe bien enfin en fait mais
après il joue pas mal la France
genre mais bon moi je le truc c'est mais
qui m'impressionne que je m'attendais
pas à toi c'est Rabi ou quoi
il fait vraiment une très très bonne
Coupe du monde
parce que normalement en fait le mieux
j'étais à 5h quoi ça sans compter Pogba
il est jeune c'est sa première saison
Réal c'est pas dit qu'il va arriver à
assumer rabiot
tu dis bon c'est pas mal rabihan
normalement mais ça va être dur que tu
cherches chaque match qu'il assume à
fond en fait il fait du monde énorme il
joue dans quel club
et d'ailleurs la Juve ça se passe pas si
bien enfin ce que j'allais dire
la juvise en fait
tu me dis ouais je te mets pas de balle
à la place va jusqu'au rabio joue je me
dis bah en fait c'est peut-être mur
radio enfin donc c'est assez étonnant en
fait qu'il soit aussi fort enfin moi je
m'y attendais pas voilà ta Griezmann qui
est complètement ressuscité peut-être
même c'est il y a peut-être jamais été
aussi fort
alors que en début de saison il jouait
30 minutes par match à peine avec
l'Atletico et
c'était dur mais là en fait il joue en
fait tout se passe bien enfin c'était
dur de prévoir ça avant le tournoi quoi
de te dire que c'est bien se passer pour
ça c'était une possibilité en fait c'est
que des mecs bons quand même
il est plus tout jeune bah il tient tous
les matchs Mbappé bon on s'attend ce qui
joue bien mais il joue bien
ok moi je suis pas fan du profil du
joueur mais je veux dire bon il fait sa
coupe du monde il revient défendre et
puis voilà
et la défense qui normalement est un
sujet un peu d'inquiétude pour l'instant
ça tient quoi on prend un but par match
mais c'est pas non plus les vannes
complètement ouverte donc
après Killian il est stratosphérique
aussi
ouais mais genre même le match contre la
Pologne en fait je trouve qu'il rate
plutôt sa marmiton mais après [ __ ] les
deux buts qui marquent
il y en a pas beaucoup qui vont faire ça
quoi
et vraiment bon dans les matchs
en fait là il fait vraiment beaucoup de
bien parce que justement il joue
plusieurs rôles à la fois dans l'équipe
quoi en fait
il descend enfin il revient défendre il
organise le jeu enfin il joue un peu
deux trois rôles en même temps c'est il
a le coffre il est précis enfin
il est vraiment important
mi Platini pierre-là un peu ça enfin
je sais pas bon on verra bien
ça peut s'arrêter de la demi-finale
contre le Maroc mais quoi qu'il en soit
plutôt une bonne Coupe du Monde quoi
qu'il en soit
puis bon normalement voilà ils sont
plutôt favoris et c'est pas un match à
raté quoi
il est parti pour jouer 50 cours
attention quand même une petite
fourchette
vraiment je sais pas
potentiellement c'est une des meilleures
de l'histoire je suis pas enfin
franchement j'en sais rien en fait j'ai
pas de match de ouf en fait déjà donc
c'est un problème mais
après je veux dire ça joue pas non plus
mal enfin ça va quoi des meilleurs coups
de l'histoire ils disent bah je sais pas
ouais je pense que c'est un peu
j'ai l'impression loin de là non
enfin déjà
mais plutôt par la surprise
ouais alors après je sais pas si parce
qu'il y a des surprises c'est très bien
enfin
comme si tu as un Roland-Garros c'est
que
tous les mecs se font éliminer alors je
sais pas oui tu as des surprises mais
est-ce que c'est bon signe ou pas je
sais pas en fait
mais oui sur le papier
tu dis ouais c'est cool
parce qu'il y a une vraie rivalité etc
mais
bon après ils ont vraiment pas voulu
leur place les crottes après
la vérité
j'ai juste vu des morceaux ou des
extraits ou des résumés
non mais globalement en fait c'est un
peu comme d'hab musique qui défendent
vont plutôt loin quoi
pour cette histoire de meilleur ou pas
meilleur Coupe du monde je pense pas que
ça du tout la meilleure après elle est
pas horrible non plus enfin ça va
c'est peut-être aussi maintenant que le
les clubs sont devenus tellement plus
fort que les équipes nationales
peut-être ça nuit un peu Coupe du Monde
aussi
Coupe du Monde de 70
le Brésil il était nettement plus fort
que tous les clubs au monde
probablement alors que maintenant les
clubs sont nettement plus forts que les
équipes nationales
moi après des fois tu as des belles
que les mecs puissent entrer tous les
jours ensemble vs unique nationale
rassemble une fois par mois maxi ou tous
les trois mois ou deux semaines en une
coupe du monde ça aura toujours plus
automatismes
et tu vois c'est ce qui existe pas
encore quand on parle sans différents
avec le rugby au rugby les équipes
nationales ça reste plus fort
nettement plus fort
c'est même dans l'intensité des matchs
c'est pas la même chose l'équipe
nationale c'est nettement au-dessus
mais là quand même l'intensité ça envoie
mais oui c'est vrai que les clubs comme
tu fais un peu un All-Star Game avec tes
équipes tu prends le meilleur d'une
équipe de si de ça de machin
après je sais pas ouais moi j'ai une
question je me posais c'est est-ce que
finalement cette règle des 5 changements
enfin même voir 6
ça va pas favoriser bien défensifs qui
ont courir comme des oufs et qui peuvent
faire cinq remplacements
comme tu peux mais jouer pour fatiguer
l'adversaire c'était clairement pas con
quoi
là je dis pas que ça vient débile mais à
droite de changement de plus donc
peut-être ça devient plus rentable de
d'avoir ce stratégie et que ça ni veille
plus finalement
donc à voir ça c'est juste une question
dans une ville ils ont fait la nouvelle
règle où tu peux sortir et rentrer quoi
ok mais ça d'ailleurs je
me demandais pourquoi finalement une
fois que tu es sorti pourquoi tu c'est
fini
non mais c'est pas con bah oui tu peux
pas un nouveau remplacement
ça fait deux remplacements bon c'est la
vie 5 remplacements mais en mode ou tu
as un mec qui peut sortir
en placement tu as les trois qui peuvent
sortir mais que c'est que ceux qui sont
sortis peuvent re-rentrer à la place
d'autres
pourquoi pas en fait il ferait sortir à
la 45e tu as un autre gars qui rentre et
en fait elle a 70e tu rentres contre
quelqu'un d'autre
c'est pas con ça
connexion qui fait un peu n'importe quoi
ça
je crois qu'il a encore plus fort que
Mbappé non merde complètement cheaté
c'est juste n'importe quoi non
bah ouais ouais c'est pas mal
du Japon ils ont fait des trucs
intéressants allez le Japon en fait moi
j'étais content qu'il se fasse éliminer
ce qui m'énerve il me saoule avec leur
esprit shonen blue log de je sais pas
quoi là ça dégage non mais j'en ai marre
ces trucs d'esprit shonen et tout fin
c'est bon c'est l'impression que les
comme des gamins dans un dans un dessin
animé quoi enfin ça va
ça
quoi il jouait par Haku mais
complètement
à se prendre des coups mais ils étaient
là et d'un coup tu partais dans tous les
sens il quoi comme des malades en 5
minutes 5 10 minutes et après repartez
tous derrière
insérer la vis quoi
c'est juste que j'en ai marre ce truc à
toutes les sauces dès que tu as un mec
complètement nul qui va réussir quelque
chose c'est esprit shonen non c'était un
looser quoi enfin encore là c'est des
joueurs professionnels bravo là pour les
joueurs japonais félicitations à ceux
qui sont en équipe nationale et ce qui
réussissent mais tu as l'impression dès
que tu lis un truc sur un truc dès que
tu lis quelqu'un de lambda qui veut
faire un truc semi-landa tu as assez
esprit shonen esprit je fais rien du
tout tu vas tu rentres chez toi quoi
en fait ce truc de c'est l'expression en
soi qui m'énerve du coup à cause de ça
c'est très content que tu as été éliminé
regarde
là c'est beau ce que toi aussi tu es
d'accord là c'est beaucoup
mais ouais le Japon 2018 c'était plus
cruel peut-être que là ils ont perdu de
tir au but ça peut arriver quoi
un peu perdu Fab qui est un peu perdu sa
connexion mais ça
il y a 5 points
il va y avoir en gros 8 9 parties donc
faut que les vannes quasi tout
le moment c'est mathématiquement gagner
alors je sais pas ça flemme de calculer
vous avez perdu contre la Belgique non
du coup le Japon ouais en 2018 ils
avaient deviné
de zéro
et puis le dernier but en plus le
premier la dernière seconde je crois
un contre éclair alors qu'ils ont un
corner ou un truc comme ça non mais
après ils ont pas chialé
non
japonais on avait le plus le ballon
machin ou quoi enfin
digne dans la défaite quoi on était
meilleur non de la chance ce machin
qui fait sa partie là il bouffent les
pions
une énième fois
ce champ là qu'il soit contre le jeu
nulle part quoi
c'est terrible pour les vents
ible en fait
de dominer que c'est n'importe quoi et
puis qu'en fait tu peux jamais gagner
quoi
c'est vraiment
souvent le cas en plus qu'on serait Caro
c'est scénario
et puis là ça va jouer pendant longtemps
qui va se résoudre à l'année quoi je
sais pas tout ça je sais pas ce qui joue
en fait il peut juste répéter et puis
peut-être que ça le fait chier de jouer
des parties aussi peut-être que c'est
les vannes qui veut que ça dure
on s'en fout il a perdu le match
et envie il joue des coups
OK
c'est trop il joue pas si mal en deux
lettres bon là avec 5 points d'écart
évidemment il a aucune chance mais
non mais franchement dans le contenu il
a fait un bon match alors un moment il a
fait sa gaffe il s'est planté B3 il a
fait deux trois petits craquages et ça
c'est beaucoup jouer à la souris sinon
mais
écoute le match
[Musique]
meilleur match que ce que à quoi je
m'attendais
peut jouer mieux que ce qu'il a fait là
quoi mais après ça fait quelques
semaines qui s'est mis à moins bien
jouer la ICO sur les tournois
bizarrement vu qu'il est revenu dingue
là
je le trouve un peu moins sur tous les
trucs que tu le vois un peu moins au
dessus
j'ai raté un truc
une pièce de plus une bonne position et
j'ai fini par me faire piéger mais
j'allais pas du tout de rajout avec plus
simple je l'aurais sûrement gagné mais
3 + 0 la pression la pendule fait trop
mal mais il a un poil moins au-dessus
alors il est évidemment au dessus hein
peu moins aérien
aujourd'hui il a pas du tout c'est clair
un peu moins
un peu comme le match aujourd'hui reste
au dessus parce que la marge est énorme
un peu moins que d'habitude quoi
et après ce qui sera de nouveau très
aérien
en demi-finale contre farine ouais si il
joue comme ça c'est pas sûr à 100 % qui
battent ça rime
[Musique]
mais bon après ça a tellement suffit que
on sera un Magnus pour ce qui est favori
ben il n'a jamais gagné contre Magnus
donc
entre Magnus si comme ça c'est même pas
qu'il est pas favori c'est que c'est 95
mais c'est pas sûr qu'il joue comme
aujourd'hui
le seul truc qui me fait dire ouais que
je sais pas enfin d'habitude en fait il
te smash s'il peut se matcher il va pas
se dire oui bon ça va je gagne je m'en
fous je vais y aller tranquille et
peut-être qu'il y a un peu il est plus
petit il a 35 ans machin
qui peut être 30-0 mais 30-0 en fait il
est pas se dire oui bon je vais gagner
23,7 ça a gagné facile aussi et c'est
tranquille quoi
peut-être qu'il a moins d'énergie
qu'avant ou peut-être qu'il prend le
match facile la streamer avant là et
qu'il a comme il est un peu moins fort
enfin fort en terme de force physique
qu'avant
il lui manque un peu d'énergie terrestre
peut-être qu'il a une meuf ouais
c'est quand même cette partie là il va
peut-être pas la gagner alors que vu le
temps et vu la position
mais tu vois tu sens qu'il y a des
petits trucs comme ça qui sont un peu
moins oui je suis d'accord
genre on dit avant le match que il gagne
que de 7 8 points tu vas être surpris
quoi
match en rapide ta vie en dépense je
préfère avoir un Prague ou MVV prime
l'un des deux mais en chaise boxing
non mais en fait la question ça dépend
tu vois si je joue l'un contre l'autre
j'ai un son je préfère avoir maca parce
que le match up a toujours
favorisé Naka je sais pas pourquoi c'est
comme ça c'était le jeu du joueur mais
genre dans toute leur rencontre sur
internet et même mon petit joint en vrai
en fait Maxime avait un peu du mal après
en soit c'est un tournoi où il y a
d'autres joueurs la question peut se
poser vraiment quoi
mais si c'est du 1 V1 en fait dans leurs
affrontements a eu l'ascendant ok je
sais pas pourquoi c'est comme ça quoi
on s'attendait pas non plus à 15 points
d'écart dans ce match ça attendait au
moins à 10 points
c'est pas du tout c'est juste que
des fois tu as des matchs qui marchent
bien dans un sens dans un autre
ça peut être pareil dans d'autres sports
au tennis ou quoi
passer dans tout pareil en fait
alors je sais pas tu vois 100 euros
contre sa fille
bon tu vas pas me dire ça aurait pu
faire que ça fine normalement quoi je te
prends exprès un exemple
normalement le consensus c'est clair
quoi enfin ça finit à gagner Grand
Chelem il était vraiment mondial enfin
bon ok quoi 100 euros très bon joueur
mais je veux dire c'est juste
normalement voilà c'est clair qu'il est
plus fort quoi
je sais pas combien il a gagné
juste une fois mais il y a vraiment un
score hyper positif quoi il y a des fois
c'est comme ça en fait un match up qui
fait que tu arrives pas quoi
là ça doit être nul j'imagine l'objectif
effectivement mais
même sur internet ça clique pas non mais
en fait c'est tu te rends pas compte tu
as 23 la différence de niveau entre Naka
et aaronian c'est pas possible où tu te
rends pas compte du format du speech
mais avec 15 points d'écart c'était
possible en fait pas 15 mais onze ou 12
enfin rien que là c'est les deux
premiers veulent illégales il y aurait
déjà 7 points et Naka il fait vraiment
pas un grand match
mais de toute façon enfin l'algorithme
je sais pas combien il donnait de
le score je sais plus
voilà ça se voit que là c'est déjà pour
toi non
mais tu vas même peut-être voir comment
ça jouer le gars avec les blancs en fait
je voulais garder peut-être pas mais tu
vas peut-être forcer
non mais par exemple c'est fou ça il
part d'une finale où il est mieux
à ça non
non non mais il joue pas très bien j'en
ai
rien c'est standard moi j'aimerais bien
jouer comme ça mais
on était habitués
enfin quand même
heureusement quand même
voilà ça y est ça a tué mathématiquement
le match
Fab ouais
mais ouais non ça se sera ça sera pas
jouer à grand chose si parce que tu sens
qu'il y a quand même beaucoup de marge
encore mais
dans le contenu
pas du tout en dessous
non non
pas en dessous
mais pas au dessus
non
on le voit pas mais il doit rester allez
20 minutes je sais pas un peu moins pire
je vais dire je veux dire
15 minutes
il reste en gros cinq parties
en fait c'est plutôt il plutôt favori
à chaque partie donc le fait d'en jouer
beaucoup ça enlève la possibilité de
d'exploit il est assez stable
normalement c'est pas un mec qui fait
des gafs Figaro donc là en fait quand tu
fais que jouer que jouer que jouer que
jouer s'entendre de repos tu peux faire
des trucs comme la partie d'avant il
vient de finir une tour en un coup
donc il va te ramasser des points
gratuits que tu n'auras pas le même truc
dans l'autre sens
vraiment moi
aujourd'hui pour le coup là tu me dis
que c'est plus mais oui non là c'est
enfin c'est clairement beaucoup moins
bien que ce qui fait normalement
d'habitude c'est
c'est chirurgical
heureusement que ça gaffe un peu aussi
côté les vannes et c'est normal que ça
gaffe mais je veux dire ouais c'est moi
parce qu'elle était vraiment très bien
et tout d'un coup il a choque alors
après contre choc de Levan
en tout cas ça suffira pas contre un
Magnus non peut-être pas contre d'autres
déjà qu'on ne farine
là il s'en sort mais finalement il a
redonné
autre chose qui aurait pu juste gagner
au noir
ça a bien tourné mais tu dois jamais une
fois que tu te retrouves complètement
gagnant entre te retrouver dans des
talents
étonnant Fab
ouais ben écoute après il fait pas très
en forme ces temps-ci c'est comme ça il
reste humain quoi
il couvre peut-être quelque chose
est-ce que tu penses que les Vans
va stop le match
non
je pense qu'il va même pas y penser quoi
et toi tu as pensé
je suis pas sûr pas
avant le match j'irai pensé mais là
pendant la tu vois tu cliques tu cliques
et puis tu oublies tout en fait
c'est même plus combien de temps il
reste tu sais plus rien quoi
ouais tu sais quoi
je crois qu'il a complètement explosé
depuis un long moment
parce qu'il est tellement pas si loin
quoi
de bouger ses pièces il gagne presque
ouais
peut-être qu'il bouge quelques pièces
mais
bon
n'importe quoi
la caméra elle est bonne
ça marche pas
ouais c'est dur c'est quand même malgré
tout ça fait quand même plus suite c'est
quand même énorme
il est là dans les moments importants et
il est là quand il faut faire la diff
il met un peu de piment dans la partie
c'est pas grand chose c'est solide et là
tout d'un coup
joueur de
de la part de Les Vans quand même
bon
s'il y a plus de l'attaque
et il a cette pièce de plus on va voir
si convertit
[Musique]
ok ça va gagner
en plus
et à profiter des
occasions
ce que ça va jouer des plans
bizarre
quand même
enfin si il gagne pas
ça ça va gagner quand même
raison c'était pas la technique
immaculée
en vrai ça le rapproche encore de la
victoire quoi
beaucoup plus que prévu en fait
non mais il va peut-être pas gagner ça
non
faire quoi tourger de peut-être
ouais mais il va lui jouer ça encore
pour faire tourner le temps
important
[Musique]
imagine le temps que ça lui fait gagner
en fait il reste plus 3 minutes 30 après
celle-là
Evan il est saoulé ouais
après pour moi ce match il est encore
plus sûr que karwana Carlson en soi
car on incarne scène tu te dis ce que je
sais pas pourquoi il joue bien en blitz
il est très instable Carole et même
contre Ikaru en fait ce serait plus
serré pour moi
il avait même gagné une section du
grand chasseur Paris elle a fini devant
Maxime 3e ou 2e ampli j'ai plus qu'à les
grandes chaise tour papa Paris mais un
autre
et du coup caroanna ouais il peut avoir
des fulgurances quoi
c'est quand c'est demain il y en a tous
les jours WSM pas de chance
ouais
Carlson contre carbona même si oui c'est
99% mais là pour moi c'était vraiment
100% ce match là
en tout cas bravo à bravo mais le match
contre Sarine
si joue comme ça c'est 55 quasiment
des 1800 avant bon
ça peut être pas aidé
faut pas que tu fasses la même prépa
quoi
normalement il aime bien c'est des trucs
sur Internet il est multiple tenant du
titre donc
ça attendre de le voir si des sa
couronne sans lutter à 100% quoi
ça serait étonnant
le Magnus
et Maxime contre saut après demain
donc on pourrait avoir une demi-finale
Carlson mvl éventuellement
ça dépend plus de nouvelles que de
Carlson à mon avis
oui Carson
il a un quart difficile contre saut mais
ça portait mais je veux dire c'est
compliqué quoi pour tout le monde
c'est pareil c'est les deux joueurs qui
évitent les tops mais qui joue les
autres quoi en fait
et je ne pose pas simple c'est ça
ce qui est beau c'est que le match est
déjà fini en terme de temps mais ko
quand même jouer le plus longtemps
possible
et ben voilà je crois que c'était la
dernière Fab donc victoire 15 à 8
merci les amis d'avoir suivi ce match on
vous envoie sur la chaîne de cheesecom
et on se retrouve demain pour la suite
de la compétition normalement à 19h si
ça change pas parce que aujourd'hui ça
devait être à 19 mais ça a été décalé à
21h sur le tard donc je vous dis à
demain ciao ciao
bonne nuit